[Music]
you found yourself at the junction where
worlds meet politics civility how about
honesty in this country folks
entertainment and a whole bunch of other
stuff about having a healthy body image
give a very unhealthy body you should
have a horrible body it's not a big
coming through the market maturity we
are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio strangest
animal
[Music]
you're getting louder with Crowder
[Music]
there we go that is it first time full
body dancing sandwich better that is not
a Jared better that is the sound of the
weekend allotted with credit or calm for
all sources my producer and video studio
as always is Jared who is not gay you
can follow him on Twitter at not gay
Jared I fulfilled my legal obligations
and draw your own conclusions we good
we're good thank you
we're good we're good gosh so yeah
notice anything I'm trying to think of
what it is yeah I'm at a loss well
that's often the case this is nothing
that we are in a brand new studio people
can't see listening to rest really brand
new video studio getting ready to launch
daily with CR T V ladder with credit um
slash mug Club to join good I'm how to
breath dancing that's how out of shape I
am and I have this horrible haircut they
cut it too short happens it has that
balding baby eagle look you can see this
is actually a placeholder neon sign here
that's gonna be ladder with credit we
got not cage areas he's so far away he's
in a different room and miles a lot of
work hold on a second before we discuss
that big show shell really big show live
in studio our biggest our biggest ever
we're one of DK Dean Cain via satellite
first off its 100th episode 100th
episode what happen I don't know someone
someone made a mistake in payroll
there's a glitch and eventually someone
will fix the glitch that'll be myself
because its name we mean with the pig
that's what you have to do and dinking
tell me Sotomayor mmm-hmm Courtney's cos
in studio and a big get we've got an
exclusive you don't know this Fidel like
the fidel fidel from hell the late for
them you have fidel from hell we will
actually have fidel via live broadcast
from the gates of hell from from from
Hades that's down there that is again
yeah it's again there are suction stuff
done that Skype it is tough I like to
take you know breaks between the
pre-scheduled raping so it is a tough
tough go but we're in a new studio thank
you so much for everyone who's been
supporting us for years and that looks a
little more professional but don't be
worried but not your heart be troubled
this is still a circus still to go
smoothly and this is my gosh this is our
first show in a couple of
we didn't do a show for Thanksgiving so
a lot has happened a lot of cabinet
picks from Donald Trump a lot of news
let me bring this up on my screen I just
appear
oh that's right I gotta send my computer
we have this whole new software here
that we need to do so that not gay
Jarrod can actually this is just
ridiculous it's so ridiculous to have to
be professional for no good reason
there's no good reason to really be
professional you got it yeah we got it
you're right you got my screen a few big
cabinet picks so we'll talk about that
what we want to see what you think you
can't win me a desk read what you think
what the cabinet picks I'm a big fan of
price auntie Obamacare hopefully here's
what's great about it Barack Obama's
whole legacy
never happen that's all like a candle
you know well we get those rainbow
colored white houses anymore I don't
know if I'll get the rainbow colored
white houses is something that I have no
idea the old Wikipedia I very much doubt
that we will something happened though
this week with carrier so this isn't you
want to talk about no we want to talk
about Fidel we want to talk about OSU
and have some rebuttals here today
because I've been been brewing with them
with Adam ruins everything in the
electoral college why it matters hint
I'm a supporter and Vox a--'s new anti
Obamacare video but carrier Donald Trump
has basically made a deal here's the
thing people know that I am NOT an
economic protectionist the whole I'm
going to tax you thirty five percent if
you outsource some jobs I'm like no I
want Ford to leave Michigan I'd rather
they go to Texas not Mexico but you
can't force people as a member of the
government to stay in states where
unions have them by the short hairs but
with carrier he did save up to a
thousand jobs liberals are quoting eight
hundred and some are still going to
Mexico that's true through tax breaks
and what's so funny is when you see
leftist we'll come back to this Bernie
Sanders he wrote this socialist screen
this is corporate tax breaks they're
giving more tax breaks I'm screwing that
worker because he's actually providing
tax incentives and the thing is with the
tax incentives not a bailout here's the
deal of people understand with carrier
and this is why I'm actually glad that
Donald Trump has done this as opposed to
a 35% tariff tax incentives to stay in
Indiana see that's brilliant that's an
easy way to start let me give you exact
a thirty two percent corporate tax rate
right let's let's use alone thirty two
percent in my estimation that's robbery
thirty two percent tax you're taking it
from a bit you're punishing a business
for creating jobs you're punishing a
business for creating wealth
now when you bail out a business what is
that well thirty two percent of stuff to
the business and then you're taking
money from the taxpayer which I also
believe is theft to bail out of business
from whom you've already committed your
act of pricking fevering thieving I
don't know if they're words that's an
oil yeah thieves oil it's true my wife
is into the essential oils so you have
double robbery so people say it's
corporate welfare is a term Bernie's Han
Clark
welfare no well first when you give
people stuff which is what you want to
do Bernie corporate welfare is not
saying you know what we're gonna give
you a tax break meaning we're not going
to steal this money off the top that
does not cost the taxpayers the double
charge that you have when you have a
high corporate tax rate the business
goes under because of a high corporate
tax rate or it outsources and then you
bail them out so there are a lot that
remains to be there's a lot that remains
to be seen we don't know exactly what's
going to be happening with carrier I'm
always skeptically optimistic with
Donald Trump but for the left to try and
act like this is the exact same kind of
bailout policies Barack Obama it's just
moronic it's not even close you're just
looking around the studio you're just
you're just panning around you like
using these cameras okay speaking of
moronic Adam ruins everything electoral
colleges is something after Donald Trump
swept the electoral college not a
historic victory not a landslide but a
good victory and he's lost the popular
vote by a couple million votes a lot of
people saying this is unprecedented it's
not a lot of people saying this is
unfair it's not we need to do away with
the electoral college we don't and of
course Adam ruins everything at College
Humor emphasis on the college no
emphasis on the humor they've talked
about the electoral college and they've
tried to do this whole rebuttal on me
like torille college talking about why
it's no longer relevant so we are going
to get into this piece by piece Adam
ruins everything
namely correct information let's roll
the first clip every four years we hear
the words Electoral College over and
over again but we never talk about what
a ridiculous and frankly undemocratic
system it really is oh okay
undemocratic this is this is the crux of
the argument against the electoral
college right it's undemocratic yes feel
like like they fooled no that's by
design let's start with this okay the
Marley Marley was dead to begin with
right I almost use the Muppets won the
marlis marlis the heckler Marley's
that's not accurate that's not Vicky
Marley was dead to begin with the United
States has never been a democracy and
that's important because if you
understand that you look through that
prism you'll understand why the
Electoral College is necessary bring up
that those quotes that we have Jared
these are just a bunch of quotes that
you have from some of the founding
fathers or signers talking about how
pure democracy is evil it's one of the
greatest evils Benjamin Rush wrote
because pure democracy is mob rule pure
democracy is that the mob of the
majority can infringe on the rights of
the minority now I know that left us
love to act as though they're there to
help minorities but not when it comes to
the electoral college not when it comes
to someone over and in flyover state so
that is the reason for the Electoral
College we are constitutional
representative Republic we are not a
democracy so if you understand that well
then the rest of this as they're
relevant but most people don't
understand that and so there needs to be
more convincing you let's go to the next
clip the Electoral College gives vastly
more power to different voters depending
on which state they live in
bigger states nope smaller states if
your state has less people you have more
power yeah let's keep going let's go to
the next clip I don't I don't I don't
this is fun this is a problem well this
is about to actually go against
everything that they use in their
premise to begin with so that's why it's
important that clip not too many people
live in Wyoming but they have three
electoral votes or one for every 135
thousand voters California is packed
with people but they have 55 electoral
votes or one for every 411
voters and that okay so they try and
show percentage-wise that their there's
more representation with Wyoming but
even if you look at it three votes to
fifty five of California it's pretty
minut let's bring up another clip from
everyone's favorite founding father
Hamilton let's bring up the Hamilton
quote from Federalist paper 68 where he
talks about this the big reason for this
is because you can't just have people
pandering to a few big cities let's stop
by New York DC Los Angeles San Francisco
Detroit in the fifties promised him a
bunch of stuff wrap this up and go home
the whole reason to try and balance that
power is because I know these crappy
states that you think of as flyover
States will continue and we'll get to
that like Wyoming they can't have their
vote drowned out by people who are
corralled in the big cities I've talked
about this a lot this is why I left us
want you in big cities they want you on
public transport they want you to be
dependent on government services they
want you to think it's a sense of
community robbing from your brother
through taxes and bigger government
that's why they want you and Biggs is so
nice it sounds so nice but God why
Wyoming shouldn't matter as much let's
get to the next clip who cares if the
Electoral College is kooky I'm kooky I
have two turtles okay well it gets worse
because the electoral college also
creates swing states the swing states
they make election nights so exciting
kind of like when my Turtles move a
little exciting I think the fact that
the entire election is determined by
just a handful of states is really
messed up for one thing it means
presidential candidates can ignore
almost the entire country
do you not see do you see the
contradiction here do you just tried to
ignore the entire country
lie over that well elvers genius flyover
by oming whatever lawyer they
represented no now all of a sudden they
care about the little guy right because
swing states allow them to ignore the
voiceless in Wyoming who by the way
shouldn't really have that many
electoral votes to balance the
powers-that-be next clip Jared and I'm
running for president of Florida
Pennsylvania and Ohio and boy do I love
Florida oranges Philadelphia
cheesesteaks and whatever you people
like in Ohio the rest of the country can
go suck a big one hi America I'm running
for president for Florida Ohio
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan Virginia
swing states change you dumbass
swing states change that's the whole
point twin states don't say the same as
party flat platforms change at the
principle change you see that with
Donald Trump he's shaking up the whole
map these things well we'll come back
we'll talk about this more after the
break I'm getting fired it's the new
studio it's coming over me in a way
that's
[Music]
Oh didn't see you there I was just
enjoying my nightly soak with my laden
with powder hand etched mug Club which
you can now receive at the library
spider calm / month club you get access
to all of lotto with powders daily
programming plus the entire CR TV lineup
for only $99 annually $69 if you're a
student or a veteran just entering promo
code student or veteran it's a great
gift to get yourself this holiday season
or even more that's special someone you
love hey Jared what are you doing
shooting bad guys with where'd you get
it
pfft not guys I'm unstated more clearly
so our audience can hear ar-15 calm
that's better
they sell guns now yeah they do are they
any good to the best
we're from air 15 accom kapoor come on
you really make that sound they doubt
the budget for sound of bags with wipe
air 15 from where Fatima calm how do you
know they're bad guys
Jared's in burkas kaboom that's racist
[Music]
glad to be with you glad to be back was
it the last clip we have from the
CollegeHumor deal we have one more here
hold on one second let me set this we
didn't want to go into the second
segment because we have to get to OSU
and Fidel is dead King Kong Fidel is
dead what a dick
glad that he's dead so we're talking
about this the swing states that's the
big argument right Florida Ohio
Pennsylvania no those swing states
change as parties change as platforms
changes it's convenient that left us
forget this from the myth from the live
where they transfer switched of course
when they transit all the Republicans
who were not in the KKK people like
Robert Byrd who had Klan Dental in a
company car switched and it was all the
Republicans now who are racist and they
try and point to Strom Thurmond as an
example but then here they don't
acknowledge that swing states change as
we've seen with Donald Trump swing
states do change depending on the
platform's depending on the principles
and here's something that's employ this
final clip because I think it's relevant
and then we'll wrap this up okay well
thank you for the information
I cannot believe our beautiful system
has become so messed up
oh no the founding fathers designed our
system is messed up alright okay so
there you go
cheap setup the founding fathers and
they'll go into the founding fathers had
slaves and all these arguments he is
right the founding fathers did design it
this way and you have a lot of stupid
people the cumin you let cool college
men they don't understand it again they
don't understand that we're not a
democracy that we're constitutional
republic the founding fathers actually
they spent more ink on this in any other
branch of government this was
unbelievably important to them the old
quote on democracy is it's basically two
wolves on deciding which lamb to eat for
dinner I'm butchering that but that's
the quote on democracy the reason for
this is precisely to combat the kind to
the kind of I guess sort of
pseudo-intellectual
a pretentiousness that you see from the
left where they refer to them as flyover
States and what are you doin i well you
see that you did you see that just that
is stain CollegeHumor has for these
flyover States who they just talked
never been to right exactly knows we're
campaigning for a few states well here's
a good enjoys our potatoes yes and
potatoes Iowa yeah well I'm not Ohio
that's Iowa it goes in corn corn
that's Indiana the Indiana sign when you
go in as the corn and their slogan I
think says Indiana it's more than corn
then why are you showing them it's it's
we need to tell everyone that it's more
than you caught up in corn yes your work
on that it's more than corn well what do
we do when we what we shouldn't when
they come into the state show them the
corn so the disdain they have for
flyover States and then to try and act
as though they have a problem with
people campaigning only in swing states
well listen swing states matter now they
campaign they're strategically because
these are actually generally areas of
middle America places that would be
underrepresented if not for the
electoral college really what would you
do New York DC Los Angeles San Francisco
Detroit back in the 50s where you
promise a bunch of Union handout Chicago
or you cater to the Union thugs and then
all of a sudden next thing you know
people in South Dakota's are paying for
some guy in Los Angeles to take a dump
in a [ __ ] designated bathroom that's
what we don't want to happen we don't
want to burden the rest of the country
with values that not only do they not
share but are unconstitutional right
that we're so far away from federalism
and this is why we have term limits this
is why representatives are selected or
you know depending what you're talking
about
legislators right it's a representative
Republic we should have terms we should
be changing these politicians regularly
but their job is to represent people and
make decisions not simply to go all
right put everything to a popular vote
that's the Bernie Sanders it's
democratic socialism I know this isn't
socialism but its funnier to the Gilbert
Godfrey well democratic socialism
doesn't change what it is democratic
slavery isn't any better democratic I
don't know cheating it POG the point is
just because people vote for something
it doesn't make it okay and that is why
but googling Paul right now we're
googling party you're doing pot genies I
was I was fantastic at the POG I shark
kids in the school I did the point I got
a detention because I was sharking them
gambling I actually I don't know how to
play wack I'm taking all your pogs
this is the takeaway people who say the
electoral college needs to be done away
with first off many of them never even
thought about it until the professor
brought it up after this election
because Jill Stein wants a recount
apparently she thinks she has a solid
chance of winning Wisconsin and they
don't understand that the United States
is not a democracy
they don't understand why this matters
they don't understand why the balance of
power matters and they don't understand
why we don't want to be simply like
Europe they don't understand the
principles behind federal
some behind enumerated powers why states
should have their own autonomy and why
representatives should be choose to buy
should be chosen by a legislature and
why they should be representing not only
the people but first and foremost the
Constitution this is one thing too from
the left we've talked about this a lot
they all they're always caring about
diversity diversity well they don't
really care about this kind of diversity
right the Electoral College is a great
representative it's emblematic of
intellectual diversity right it's it's
emblematic of making sure that people
can have diverse states microcosms petri
dishes so you can have crappy ones that
have salmonella on their petri dish like
California or you can have a vibrant
successful one like a strong kefir
culture there in Texas because of
intellectual diversity I don't care
about the cultural diversity in the same
way that left us - I don't care about
the racial diversity at all I certainly
don't care about the gender diversity
because of the LGBTQ AIP we don't know
what that means
I want intellectual diversity with
constitutional conformity borderline
constitutional fascism no wiggle room
with the Constitution intellectual
diversity constitutional conformity
that's the Electoral College did I
hopefully explain that well enough I
think that's pretty well explain it all
right I think we explained it well
enough what do we have here oh well OS
the OSU situation mm-hm have you been
following this I have in a little bit
here's what I find funny this guy the
attacker I don't know if you can see
this he tried to claim shoe it was like
19 or something did you see that nuts he
definitely was a college student he's
bald with a grain beard it's and this is
again with the refugee laws it pays to
be younger so Isis has claimed some sort
of credit he claimed it was influenced
by Isis we don't want to jump to
conclusions but you can draw your own
conclusions and Courtney we'll talk
about this later on this week has been
so effective at showcasing you know
BuzzFeed got really mad with the fixer
upper stars chip and Joanna Gaines they
have this up on my screen because one of
their pastors so I have this year that
one of their pastors was firmly against
same-sex marriage right so we're really
upset they want to try and excoriate
these people publicly destroy their
career because they have a pastor who's
against same-sex marriage now we flip it
to Ohio attacker claims Isis and Isis
says yeah we're gonna go with that net
on that love you guy hold on a second
what if he just went to a mosque and his
pastor was against gay man
so the same week that they're trying to
destroy people's careers for reality
show because their church is against
same-sex marriage by the way not even
hateful of gay people they are just not
Pro same-sex marriage these people can't
be tolerated
someone who slaughters people the name
of Isis Isis says yeah yeah we're glad
that we inspired that we have to reserve
judgement the hypocrisy knows no bounds
and here's the problem with the
hypocrisy it's funny for our show I know
I laugh at it we have dark humour of
course and we're not going to stop but
political correctness is actually taking
lies because people are so distracted
with the gay bakeries and the gay
pizzerias and not gay pizzeria is that
people are killing in record numbers in
Islam pay no attention behind the
curtain Dean Cain coming up next stay
tuned
[Music]
you
[Music]
I'm now home alone but realistic now as
you can see Your Honor this case goes
far beyond the scope of basic burglary
here we see aggravated assault but more
importantly child abuse possibly
cannibalism and even pedophilia as the
tapes could reveal what I intend to
prove today ladies and gentlemen of the
jury is that marvin harry are not merely
armed robbers looking to feed their
family down on their luck but they are
cruel sadistic bloodthirsty and should
never have a place in civilized society
again overruled
stay tuned from all home alone but
realistic
[Music]
[Music]
and glad to be back our guests perfectly
fitting for the 100th episode unlike my
dance I need to get you know it's been
too long with the Christmas set we
weren't able to do the dancing the same
everything ruins everything
one of our favorite guests of course
coming off a failed vice presidential
campaign we're a little disappointed in
that but he's been doing fantastic work
hosting the Today Show I've watched him
I think he's doing it again on December
14th you know him on the Twitter as real
Dean Cain mr. Cain thank you for being
with us sir on the Twitter thank you oh
look at there that mug it's a good mug
we're daily and you said you put that in
the dishwasher which you're not supposed
to but it held up the red is still there
everything worked fine yeah Rach no
problem there you go for people who
don't you're not supposed to it's but
it's more so because those are
hand-painted you might lose some of the
colors you're not gonna get asbestos or
cancer
I also Drive a truck and my truck
doesn't always look perfect either I
just a little bit rugged it's okay this
is true unfortunately many people drive
the big trucks you know small penises
but we know that's not the case with
Dean Cain we have verifiable proof
ladies Newman yes small truck it's the
Toyota truck well it will end much like
you know what the Ford trucks we punish
men who take their penis to Mexico so
there's patriotism so Dean you were on
the live election night our broadcast
and we didn't really know what was going
because you were on earlier in the
evening you're in Los Angeles you're in
Hollywood
how how cathartic has it been to just
watch the entire city lose its mind I
ended up hangover after the election
because I was just watching it and so
stunned I kept just sipping wine and it
just kept going so my head hurt very
much the next day uh and apparently
California is gonna secede from the
union apparently that's real oh yeah I
wouldn't be voting for that I was really
fun to watch the evening go through and
see that it all the pundits who had been
screaming about there being no chance I
literally thought Hillary who's gonna
win I'd said that that day
we both did but we we both thought there
was obviously like we always had about
60/40 Hillary Trump and I always said it
was more likely than the media thought
possible and less likely than the Trump
supporters guaranteed we're gonna ignore
that phone call telemarketers in 2016
[Laughter]
got a great roll for you to follow up on
the hosting Today Show they want you for
a Hallmark Hanukkah film so I just did a
homework though I would do a second yeah
so long as the shekels cash thing with
lifetime my wife won't stop watching
lifetime Christmas films have you been
in a lifetime Christmas film
[Music]
yes did you push any woman down a flight
of stairs because usually that occurs on
a lifetime not on camera okay not on
camera this is true it was just your
agent again oh come on
let's see
whoo hey I have to come right back okay
is this thank you
cuz that your agent boom you're right so
that was my agent Wow well we know
someone's gonna fire you're more
important than my age well thank you and
that not gay Jerrod guess is true well
we know that all too well now we know
Dean Cain is the one guy who answered
the landline polls and we're saying no
one asked me well they were asking Dean
400 times he was their sample size yeah
well yes little bit different so you
were so you thought Hillary would win
but you weren't stunned that Trump won
no I wasn't stun there's a lot of people
talking about me when you shows up with
those rallies and that many people are
there and and the people that I would
talk to once I got below the the sort of
top line hate which everyone just going
oh it's so embarrassing it's so terrible
right and then started getting into
talking about policy or things I found
that a lot of people were were more
lined up with mr. Trump's policies
president-elect Trump's policies and
things like that I thought you know what
there there could be a shot and
certainly judging by the rallies I
thought maybe there's a possibility but
for me it was kind of a pipe dream I'm
so excited to see change in Washington I
can't stand it yeah of course he's gonna
have some insiders and some guys who
have been there before
but it's a whole new ball of wax and for
me that's exciting because I think we
were headed down a very very bad what
does the reaction bin from your your
your buddies in the entertainment
industry are they like wanting to
swallow a knife are they let's give him
a chance are they already caridina ng
from their beams and their porch what's
going on
well it's shocking to see how many
people are just so distraught as though
the world is going to end you know
I love it can't understand that it's
just you know that omekata such hate I
mean there is that huge indoctrination
that's going on through the colleges and
it's it's ridiculous and my son's about
to go to college and I promise you it's
not going to happen where he goes to
school now or they're certainly not
getting any of my money yeah it doesn't
make any sense to me I'm a history major
I'm a very patriotic American I traveled
the world I know what it's like to not
have the Bill of Rights and to have the
freedoms that we have and to think that
this guy is going to come in I use the
words like dictator or tyrant or you
know of course the rate the race is
sexist
that just becomes the same little mantra
it means nothing so to see it to see
everybody flipping out as soon as they
watched well I was gonna say as soon as
they watch the the Dow hit its all-time
high which of course it already has done
right and see things turn around and
things start to change I think that
they'll be really a lot less the truths
with that market - it was like when
people had to say well equities have
done better under Obama than anyone else
I said well hold on you have to remember
that there was the crash before Obama
but then before he became president all
of that risk was built in and when he
wasn't as absolutely catastrophic for
markets as they thought that's when it
rallied that's the same thing with Trump
the risk the crash was built in
beforehand the uncertainty and then it
rallies back so I wouldn't so much
credit Donald Trump having done anything
that's just an example of how off you
know that the speculators are and what a
problem system that is and some of those
people in his cabinet which I'm not
thrilled about but what do you where are
you on the cabinet picks right now do
you have any that really stand out at
you I know like mr. price obviously with
Obamacare any that you're particularly
more excited about or still kind of
still kind of optimistically skeptical
well there's a few of them that I know
and so I was excited to see them get
there they're shot I was excited I was
happy to see Michelle Rhee get a shot at
Secretary of Education she didn't get it
but I know Michelle well and okay it's
like the way she goes and changes and
had you know changed that DC school
system I like like what she had done but
she's a Democrat I thought that'd be a
nice reach across the aisle I'm not
unhappy with what he's done
General Petraeus is someone I know and
really like quite a bit yeah I don't
know if Secretary of State is a spot for
him I think it's really interesting to
see the Mitt Romney discussions going on
I voted for Mitt back in the day but
then once he said those things about
President Lee Trump before he was
President Elect I know people are like
oh jettison him get rid of it you know I
don't know I want the best people in
there
and pretty much anybody we put in in my
opinions any better than John Kerry well
that goes without saying mr. Kerry mr.
Kerry got scratched by a grain of rice
Purple Heart I uh but you know I will
say this though here is the scary part
not get you ready it sounds like a
rotary phone in my ear are you here
that oh maybe it's just me it could just
be my new earpiece be ah to hell with it
it could be the demons in my head this
is this has been described before I
guess the medication needs to be up to a
slight slight dosage not good there this
is this is your job you're supposed to
take care of these things now that we're
a full-scale operation some new ones for
you later
John Kerry here's a good example though
what concerns me is Donald Trump he you
know the three trillion dollars in
spending proposed where I was against it
when Barack Obama did it I'm of course
still against deficit spending when
Donald Trump does it people are saying
well he's a good businessperson because
interest rates are low well then by
proxy you're saying that Barack Obama
was a good businessperson so i none of
that has changed for me what worries me
is is this a little bit like he said
some good appointees some kind of
insiders certainly not necessarily
draining the swamp the democrats didn't
have any kind of a bench right you have
young kerry and then yet you did have
obama who kind of came out of nowhere
but hillary with donald trump this will
give them an opportunity to probably
build a more formidable bench you know
like in any sports team it's like okay
you have a year now that the seniors
have moved on we have a year to build a
bench for next year do you see that as
something to worry about and being in LA
you know a lot of the fundraisers take
places there have you heard any
rumblings like oh it's gonna be alan
grace and that's just clearly an insane
example but you know today show and then
after sometimes they say independent I
really declined a state I want to see
term limits I want to see you know the
23 year
congressman get out you're done you've
done enough time I really want to see
those term limits in there and things
like that so you know whether there's
gonna be a deep bench for the Republican
Party or the Democratic Party or
whichever I'm not a party guy all the
way although my I certainly lineup much
more with the Republican Party and small
government and things like that but
socials I'm very liberal in that I don't
want you know self-reliance let people
do what they want to do stay out of the
bedroom etc etc let people you know I'm
Lee I'm for legalizing regulating taxing
marijuana I'm more for you know personal
freedoms and things like that
I'm for a woman's right to choose up
until it's a viable fetus and we did a
film called Gosnell which maybe we'll
talk about a bit sure yeah that deals
with that so socially I'm in more
liberal yeah positions but but fiscal
foreign policy size of government
regulatory things I'm much more reminded
much more the Republicans and I think
Donald really is somewhere in between
and I and I really have great confidence
in his ability to pick an interesting
cabinet yeah I have a different group I
mean he doesn't have those deep ties to
Washington a different way and business
international business where you do have
to be well just like in you know you
can't really have your agent necessarily
being a producer on a film because there
can be a conflict of interest though it
happens all the time yes I know I want
the line producer credit in home for
Hanukkah so this is true yeah that was a
for your consideration home for Purim
and like just make it less Jewish turn
down that you Ness it happens a lot
really like they consult with Christians
like how do we make this more secular
these are funny conversations they're
awkward conversations that take place so
you've heard it from Dean Cain he's a
horrible liberal who wants to pay lower
taxes that's what I deserve from that
rent do you think people in law sent in
the entertain ministry or is there a
sentiment of you heard this from Tom
Hanks do you think a lot of them want to
give this guy a shot do you think a lot
of them want to see him okay let's see
what he can do or are they already just
trying to stack the deck rooting for him
to fail because I will say I was rooting
for Obama's policies to fail if they
were socialist far-left policies but I
was hoping he would succeed by coming
home to what you know made America
America that was my sentiment what's the
sentiment you think in Los Angeles with
those horrible devil people the same
thing for President Obama I was rooting
for the same thing it didn't happen that
way no here I think most everybody I
would say probably 90% want to jettison
get out run they're rooting for him to
fail etc etc etc and this
10% and everywhere there's a Mark
Wahlberg Tom Hanks or a few others that
are saying you know what give him a
chance it's a dangerous thing to go out
there and say because the the tolerant
left is not very tolerant they didn't
snip on you and call you names and
you're sexist and you're xenophobic and
you're racist and it's the exact same
words and a bigot but more infidel
Castro who was all of those things and
then some and they wear the Che Guevara
shirts and things like that and then
that stuff is just stunningly ignorant
yeah well chenkov era was just people
understand just as bad as Mussolini
Stalin Pol Pot Hitler people just
without the charm actually have a lot of
cool hat he had a cool hat and he a
horrible pubic hair beard looks like a
Taco Bell dog that was not that was not
sex no it was not sexy and here's the
thing I don't know if you know this
about Che Guevara we think about when we
have this doing the shirt back there
Jared to get the lung he had a long shot
I don't know if you know do you know
that Che Guevara never actually fought
an armed populace he never fought anyone
who was armed and when they found him
was it Arjun yeah Bolivia yeah he was he
his gun was fully loaded never fired you
some I'm worth more to you alive than
dead
this is their brilliant revolutionary
they we're gonna be back and talk about
I don't know we'll talk about Gosnell
something ethnocentric will make sure
there's a soundbite to accuse Dean Cain
of being racist real Dean Cain on
Twitter stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
former governor of Minnesota
Jesse Ventura here the bond this
election season and with today's
mainstream media it's very easy to get
sidetracked from the stories that really
matter what every tabloid on mainstream
network is focusing on the latest
hashtag or the Kardashians fad axis it
distracts Americans from the issues that
affect you like right now the historic
recon taking place in Wisconsin in my
home Rust Belt of the United States that
will reveal the corrupt political system
and the true winner of the popular vote
oneness Josh I know the facts
whereas on a party we will party hard
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is that real Dean Cain on Twitter
at real Dean Cain what's that doll who
Pablo Picasso Oh Picasso okay Paul
Begala Carlson maybe I was like he's a
real crossfire fan I feel like I feel
like Paul Begala is just like it when I
look at him I don't know anything about
him is nothing personal it is entirely
immature at hominem when I look at him I
feel like he's like a human but before
they had skin and they just had kind of
a sack and they dropped them in and then
kind of twist hide it but it's not the
right fit like one day he could unzip
himself be like actually it's me Val
Kilmer and you like that's what you've
been doing Val so yes I didn't hear you
at all so I don't even know if your mic
was on was your mic on not gay Jarrod I
can't hear you can Dean hear you
professional equipment so Gosnell the
film we've talked about this before so
Lim left me a voicemail which I never
understand and this time even all I
could understand in the voicemail was
that he was mad that I've made fun of
his voicemails on the show where you
know so even though I'm going to talk
very slowly and you'll still make fun of
it on your show that you can't
understand me of the girls no film I
still can't I said yeah
so something's going on our distribution
with the film is talking about it a lot
of people don't want to touch this
because it's of its obviously you know
controversial nature now as an actor you
may not necessarily be privy to all the
inside baseball there but are you aware
of that there have been some
complications because this isn't like
something they're now trying to bring a
distribution there were things lined up
and then people got cold feet right
listen the subject matter even when it
happened when it would actually took
place in the trial took place and things
like that the mainstream media didn't
cover and that's a big part of the story
okay so the fact that it's not finding
its distributor right now really kind of
adds that same thing this guy was a
monster
I mean it's horrific and you're looking
at you know
things like well you know like Nick
Cannon out there saying you know Planned
Parenthood is you know modern-day
eugenics and things like that
take a look at this film yeah take a
look at this film and see what happened
we don't make stuff up we don't
embellish things we actually tamped it
down in the story it's probably it's
only to make a rating right - you didn't
want this to be an R we do you didn't
want to perhaps but I mean the things
that you see in the things we have to
talk about are just so disturbing and
what you have to learn about this
process it's just horrendous you know I
do believe in a woman's right to choose
and I backed that up before and I've had
a limit and it's a tough situation
however there's a point in time where a
fetus is viable and there's a point in
time late-term abortions it just should
not be happening unless you know unless
it's the debt you know the health or you
know the life or death well let me ask
you this because I would say I disagree
with you on that respectfully but let me
ask you this because of you kind of are
stuck in a hard place right because
Republicans or people like me who are
pro-life right already people like
Christopher Hitchens where we believe
life begins at conception you're you're
or you're ending a life certainly you're
with that and you don't inherently agree
with that but on the left there are only
actual policy proposals at this point as
part of the Democratic platform is
abortion on demand any time
taxpayer-funded so does how does that
affect your voting or do you just almost
have to put it off the table because you
know it there really isn't a party for
someone like you
well I think that there isn't a party or
someone like me but I think it's worth
probably 80% of the United States of
America stacks up yeah and that's the
odd thing is it's not one absolutely
this way or absolutely this way it's
we're somewhere in between and and you
know I'm not gonna tell the woman what
you can do with her body and I may have
my own beliefs as to what is going on
religiously etc but I wouldn't you know
in this society I wouldn't if I were
governing I wouldn't be trying to change
that you know in that sense and it's
hard because I think that both parties
are polarized not just an issue but for
so many we're probably 80% of Americans
are somewhere in between I'm pretty
polarizing that issue but again that
goes to use just because if I and out
but I'll tell people I don't know I
think you know I think it's a life as a
life as a life and I also think it's
important to and I think we would agree
on this to be a culture that airs
side of life because it's such a
contrast to the cultures you know Islam
the cultures that we fight that are a
culture of death and submission and
punishment and power and I know right
now I can already see the chat letting
people yeah but they can't drive dummy
so you and I disagree on this right
prick it's fine we're having a normal
regular conversation we're still friends
we're still able to talk to each other
yeah we're not hurling insults and names
at each other and that's how it should
be and I don't know where we've gotten
to where you can't have a civil
disagreement with somebody that's
because I've seen your prints and
highlight-reel and I don't want to be
tackled although actually I've seen your
American Gladiators performance though I
think you
I think you would tackle me then you
have a world of problems on the ground
so it could go for charity they've like
Danny Bonaduce versus the Brady guy no
oh my god I know it's it's pathetic when
you have these people out there like a
celebrity boxing have you ever watched
the appeared you know not pierre gosh I
always say Pierre because I was Pierre
Elliott Trudeau Justin Trudeau the
Canadian Prime Minister have you ever
actually watched his boxing match yeah
an amateur boxing he actually won but it
was it I mean in the loosest sense of
the word it was like he was fighting a
guy who just came out I think he was a
Tory and he just came out in his birth
you know blitzed him like no technique
at all and so he was exhausted and so at
that point it allowed Trudeau with his
chin completely up and a jab that looked
like it was taking place in a hot tub -
it was like Homer Simpson nobody just
got took all the punishment and he would
just tip someone over that's what it was
and oh my gosh it is pathetic so here's
the deal no matter what happened in the
United States we are not as laughable as
Canada with that poof in there Wow I
work up in Canada quite a bit and it was
interesting because when they had a
Conservative government in power there
yeah so there they got rid of their
whole debt their debt and all of a
sudden when I would go up there instead
of them paying me everything in Canadian
dollars they started giving me like my
per diem
all sudden showed up in US dollars what
is this it's worth less than the
Canadian dollar now and you know of
course it's gone back the other way and
it's they're gonna be going down I think
Hartford I voted for Stephen Harper and
he's probably the best leader of the
United States and Canada combined that
I've seen in my lifetime now not as
conservative as we'd like in the States
but considering what he had to work with
the guy got a lot done
Dean Cain at real Dean Cain Today Show
on December 14th yes and I'm also
hosting the Christmas parade in the CW
so check that out you fit right in with
a CW a pretty skin pretty skin we'll
stay tuned
you
[Music]
on Mao home alone but realistic nothing
would thrill me more frankly to shoot
you knocking off the youngster didn't
mean all that much to me understand Your
Honor ladies and gentlemen of the jury
need i say anything else what you have
seen displayed here is a clear example
of sociopathic behavior let me repeat to
you what he said quoting a transcript
knocking off a youngster ain't gonna
mean all that much to me
ladies and gentleman I don't know about
you but I take him at his word because I
don't think that there is anything that
means all that much to people like
Marvin Harry other then quenching their
bloodlust particularly if it involves a
victim who is young helpless defenseless
and what the French call les an compact
huh Marvin Harry you are such a disease
overruled you little jerk
stay tuned from all home alone but
realistic
all right folks steven crowder here how
often do you hear me do libraries
usually once a show we don't have a lot
of sponsors we don't sell a lot of
products and that's why we started the
Mudd Club
lottery with credit com / Mudd Club a
lot of with fighters going daily not
only do you get a daily show not gay
Jared's show with Courtney and the whole
see our TV ladder with clatter team you
get access to Mark Levine Mark Steyn
Michelle Malkin 499 dollars a year or 69
dollars a month if you're a student
promo code student if you're a veteran
promo code veteran military promo code
military our friends at ar-15 comm who
are registered members you can actually
have a promo code yourself over there
our comma which again takes $30 off we
didn't want to do a patreon listen we
didn't want to ask you guys for for
money we wanted to provide so much value
that that you really wanted to subscribe
and you get this really cool mug which
by the way for people who've already
ordered them we've had many many many
thousands these are hand-painted we're
getting some more out to you anyone who
ordered before December should get it
around Christmas if you ordered after
that you'll get it in January the show
launches daily January let me tell you
the free stuff you like a lot of work
latter daily articles it's going to stay
free you don't need to complain if you
subscribe you can read all the stuff add
free and you get the additional daily
content we're not doing a
bait-and-switch we don't want to pull
anything away from you but there are
some complications we've talked about
this with with big websites whether it's
YouTube or Facebook they have the right
to pull people and they often do and
this is a way to archive our content
this is a way to make sure that we can
fight back against media and we're
providing you with options to either
join pay daily or not and here's
something else a lot of with creditors
growing you see the studio we employ
close to 10 people we're hiring more
people as well so you know not gay
Jarrod you know and loathe him but then
we also have Courtney Casey Brautigan
Erin Francine
Cory is a new writer that we have and
we're hiring two or three more people
and that's done through contributions
and viewers like you but no government
funding so louder with credit com / mug
club still get the free show once a week
you're good if you don't have the money
69 dollars a year bookmark the site
iTunes YouTube subscribe share the stuff
we appreciate it and when you do scrape
enough money together you know break
open that piggy bank if you want The
Daily Show
the Month Club lottery with credit.com
slash mug Club honestly we couldn't have
done this we couldn't have grown like
this without you
we're still glad to be partnered with CR
T V and we're bringing in some other big
names this really is the first time
there's this kind of firepower under one
roof and the partnership is fantastic
they've been so good to us frankly not
sad lot of credit comm slush mug Club if
you want to support the fight and taking
media back this is how you do it
we're all behind you and we ask that you
stand behind us because you've got glob
with my brothers now mug club with me
now I'm a cop with me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before you hate me you're burying me in
that dance you're killing me
only madam I know you've been doing it
for months bruising me in video studio
as always as my producer not kid Jarrett
he is not gay Tommy Sotomayor coming up
here's black so we're getting it just
lighting in the new studio for this I'm
not gonna lie we'll see what happens or
Joe the makeup is not I don't think we
have makeup for black people but Tommy
Sotomayor and then Courtney and coming
up we will have Fidel from hell lie
which we're looking forward to is it get
before it is a get yeah we've hired we
have a new Booker we're hiring here at
Lauder with Carter so we're getting a
lot of exclusive Conda we zoom in the
shot here a lot of people said they felt
so far away from me the shot little too
far a little closer tweet me at us
Carter do you feel better about this ARF
comm thread do you guys feel better that
you feel closer to me we have so much
space here's the truth we were offered
to go to a big giant commercial space
and do a big cable news type broadcast
and we said no no so we want to find a
space that is really small that's
intimate where we're going to actually
work here every day this is where we
work so it's very much like the old
space just better and more reliable I
know he had some audio issues with Dean
Cain that should be fixed sorry I feel
like we're talking too much but usually
we don't talk so personally there's just
so much going on what's going on it's
been such a busy couple weeks I know I
have AIDS I didn't want to just reveal
it I should have led up to that with
that work that up a little more it's
World AIDS Day I Know What You Think's
have you know what you're thinking
it wasn't behavior was gay sex and
that's the problem is it's just it's I
mean it's not soon needles I know people
to assume needles dirty needles I'm
kidding it's not I made out with mega
Johnson it wasn't magic I ruined the
work though he is kind of a maggot a
little bit Magic Johnson actually I
don't mind Magic Johnson but he does
have AIDS HIV it's funny it's a funny
gag the HIV the hip so I think okay
here's something else I wanted to talk
about we'll get to Fidel
we'll get the caper Nick we'll get to
more of the cabinet appointees but Vox
did an Obamacare video god bless them
god bless Fox
so Vox put together an Obamacare video
after the election and you know
had this at the ready because it was it
was really so quickly trying to of
course appeal to your emotions trying to
get people to feel sorry for those
enrolled on Obamacare and presenting no
really clear factual argument whatsoever
then not really the thing though it's
well it's not there for time some people
news some people art entertainment some
people just listen here's the thing you
have to be open-minded some people
specialize in watercolors
yes some people specialize in
interpretative art hmm Vox specializes
in [ __ ] it's what they do it's what
they do very well I know you're not
liking that you have to get hit hit the
dump button for terrestrial more work
for not cool traits but they did this
video and people were asking me to
address it
so alright let's just start this video
off to set the stage Vox is trying to
create a personal argument giving you a
personal example of someone on Obama
care and why it can't be repealed let's
go this is me and this is my sister
Annie she's 28 mom to two cats freelance
designer and part-time grad student with
the moms of two cats part-time grad
student is there any do you not know
right away what kind of a video this is
well that's the kind of person you're
like well they're not all super crazy
social justice leftist to our part-time
grad students and claim to be mothers to
cats
oh crap they are rather brush my teeth
or the toilet brush then watch the rest
of this alright seeing him do it
so that's not really a lofty claim for
not gauges or in other words he'd rather
go through his Thursday prep show French
so mother to few cats freelance a
freelance okay what does that mean
anyway so right away mom to two cats
part-time grad student mmm I'm willing
to bet not a particularly productive
member of society but let's roll on give
her the benefit of the cat doubt there's
just something about freelancing I feel
a lot of creative freedom she's also had
chronic back pain neck pain and
migraines for as long as she can
remember she has health insurance
through Obamacare and without it there's
no way she could afford all her doctor's
appointment
medications where'd you get coming back
from Nam I'm it was at the Korean War so
like all these pills by the way is yeah
I'm going about some of those aren't
illegal I'm wrong about some of those
are like folate or something like like
like a thyroid pill or something really
basic and she's if you need that many
pills if you are that sick probably
don't take a freelance job you probably
need to choose a job that might have
cadillac health insurance you might need
to choose a job that would provide it
for you I also wonder you may say she's
allowed to write this is the flexibility
she wants well I wonder who she hires I
wonder who she benefits let's talk about
it let's not just think about the people
the victims right who are on Obamacare
because they are taking our tax dollars
right so if we want to talk about it
takes a village in the community well
how are they benefiting the community
that's a valid question ask how is the
part-time grad student mother to cats
benefiting the community maybe they'll
maybe they'll tell us and because she
doesn't have to depend on an employer
for her insurance she's able to work for
herself the flexibility works really
well with being able to make my
appointments because she works for
herself and they're trying to convince
you that she's actually a freelancer a
legitimate writer this is her putting on
her game face this is it's a couple
mouse clicks and petting a cat we work
for herself if you could see we're not
gay Jarrod as much as I he's deplorable
he works like crazy Cortney works like
crazy we are self-employed and we now
have a great partnership with CRT we've
been self-employed for years we're not
doing a couple clicks and petting cats
so again it begs the question well what
kind of a work ethic here what kind of a
very vague goodness in describing what's
the specifics that you need to know in
order to make their emotional argument
which comes next
on election night my first thought was
what does this mean for my sister
which Obamacare is a big law with lots
of different parts and there are some
parts that Trump and the Republicans in
Congress say they want to keep for
example before Obamacare companies could
refuse to sell insurance to people with
lots of health problems
Obamacare says they can't do that
anymore and Trump and the Republicans
say they want to keep it that way the
problem is the law that they like that
they want to keep it only works because
of another piece of the law that they
don't like a piece that they've promised
to get rid of that's the part of the law
that says you have to have health
insurance or pay a fine okay here's
something that's really important a fine
and what shows up on screen for those
listening to rest Trulia 695 dollars no
no no no no no that's the minimum fine
that's the minimum fine as a matter of
fact there's a calculator right at
healthinsurance.org you enter in your
year state are you married and members
of the household and it calculates what
fine you'll actually pay it almost
invariably it's much higher than 695
dollars not to mention it's not fair at
all it's unconstitutional to for force
people to buy a private service so
justjust just don't let that be glossed
over well 695 dollars why don't you pay
for the insurance well what if it's
$1,500 first off you can't just put a
number on it but if we put a number on
it it sucks
next clip your health insurance to be
affordable you need a lot of healthy
people to sign up for every one sick
person that's because health insurance
is worth more to sick people and they'll
pay more for it which pushes up premiums
for everybody else the healthy people in
the pool consume less health care and
that helps keep the cost down mhm
if Trump and the Republicans get rid of
the individual mandate which they say
they will yes a bunch of healthy people
are gonna stop buying insurance premiums
will go up and more healthy people will
leave until all that's left are sick
people who are really expensive to cover
okay so let me understand why this is a
bad thing you mean to say that if you
remove the unconstitutional mandate
essentially forcing people at gunpoint
that's what the government does they
send in scary people with guns if you
don't do what they tell you to do you're
saying that when you remove that people
will go back to making decisions out of
their own free will as it did before
Obamacare where younger healthier people
didn't pay for insurance plans shortly
not extravagant plans that also points
out when Barack Obama used to talk about
40 something million
uninsured yeah a lot of them were young
people who chose not to be insured it's
not our job as taxpayers well it's not
the job of the government to rob us the
taxpayers in order to make up for other
young people's poor decisions right but
they're trying to present this as though
it's a bad thing they're trying to
present this as though it's a problem
let's roll the next clip
too many healthy people were choosing
the fine over health insurance and as a
result states like Alabama and Oklahoma
only have one insurance plan on the
market without competition premiums shot
up last year and if Trump and the
Republicans get rid of the individual
mandate we'll likely see this happen in
other states like Texas where my sister
lives
yes yes exactly
first up do you see what just happened
there knock AJ I think they were arguing
for competition yes it was kind of weird
stream is healthy by the way right my
selfies out they were right back and
tell me so tomorrow coming up next you
know it's so funny she was arguing for
competition she doesn't understand she
just made an argument for insurance
across we don't have time for the next
video montage do we get Mego we did she
made an argument for insurance across
state lines which I feel like I've I
feel like I've heard people talk about
this could it be the party of no with no
solutions like we should have gotten rid
of the lines around each state so we can
have real competition you should allow
people to purchase health insurance
across state lines you look at across
state line purchasing we don't need more
government in health care we need to
free people up cross state line
purchasing of health insurance allows
health plans to be portable to move with
an individual from job to job and state
to state and gives Americans a wider
range of plans
of course cool we don't have time for
the montage of people who are against
insurance across state lines we do we do
have time okay we do have time well okay
so Republicans were for insurance across
state lines I remember that because now
Vox is saying it's a problem and I
understand what they're coming from but
there was a party they were adamantly
against opening up insurance across
state lines I don't Jarrid perhaps you
can why shouldn't you be able to buy
health insurance anew and in Wisconsin
because if you do you'll buy health
insurance for a company that won't cover
women for pregnancy you'll buy health
insurance for a company that decides not
to insure any sick people and then
you'll have the same problem of skewing
the insurance pool the philosophical
concern I have on that is that you
potentially get what's been referred to
as a race to the bottom that's how you
stumble days like the philosophical
argument having its that is race and
write them yeah it's a so right away Vox
is now saying well I can't work without
the individual mandate because certain
states they can't offer competition they
can't allow health care across state
lines
well you just so you don't need the
mandate you just need to open up
insurance across state lines is what we
it's what we proposed in the fridge
let's get back and let me tie it into
the macro here stay tuned and we'll do
this will do this will do this will do
well do out will do
[Music]
four bright and new our will problem
I'm Harry Matheson without presenting an
exclusive interview with presidential
candidate Jill Stein whose demanding a
historic recount in Wisconsin's for
which she has raised a whopping four
point eight billion dollars on gohan me
miss sign thanks for taking the time you
were clearly very anti Donald Trump but
you've also made clear your disdain for
secretary Hillary close some of the
industry have the reporting on that as
you move regardless what is your motive
in demanding this recount who you
believe it will come out the victor
myself delusional we appreciate your
time as a sign will keep you abreast as
the story unfold from
[Music]
to be back that was Pogo coming up next
Tommy Sotomayor who is actually a fan of
the Pogo we've turned out a lot of
people to Pogo we're glad hopefully he
gets his work visa issues worked out we
don't have any more clips from Vox do we
no more that's good good we don't any
more clips this is what's so funny right
this is important because now they're
talking about Obamacare they're talking
about how people want to repeal it and
let me bring you back Vox is saying it
doesn't work without the health care
mandate for their part-time writer who
is a mother to two cats because there's
no competition across state lines
Republicans conservatives for the
longest time said we'll hold on a second
before we try a public option before we
go crazy let's do something as simple as
tort reform and opening-up insurance
across state lines Democrats said they
were the party of no here's the
something that really bothers me when
you watch Fox great I get it you want
free health care but you're not the only
victim you know we talked about well
what's fair what the housing bubble it's
not fair to be people for people to be
kicked out of their houses well you know
what it's not fair for people who saved
up who didn't overspend who didn't live
beyond their means and want to buy those
houses and now there's a market
opportunity for them to buy something
they can afford and have a great life
but because the government steps in and
decides that the other people can't be
kicked out that's what's fair it's not
fair for people who employ dozens of
others it's not fair for small business
owners who have crippling costs with
Obamacare so they have to lay people off
or they have to make people into
part-time workers and then Democrats
want to step in and say you can't make
them part-time workers so they have to
close their business doors because
what's fair is for the girl who's a
freelance writer for Vox and a mother to
two cats wants to pay for her pain pills
and likely birth control remember we're
footing the tab for that let's actually
get to what's fair let's ask this this
is the self-esteem generation okay Vox
sister how many people do you employ how
many people have you helped - how many
charities have you given how many other
people have you reached out and lent a
hand how many loans have you given how
many health care plans have you decided
to find for other people how many
markets have you what benefit have you
been to other people how many people
have benefited from your existence not
just what can you take from them but how
have you given to them and that's the
issue it's selfish if you want to keep
what you've earned working like crazy
but it's not selfish for this girl who's
doing two mouse clicks and petting her
cat to take from you to pay for her
birth control
pay for her vagina pills to pay for
whatever is I don't know percocet who
knows they don't want to specify so
let's stop talking about what's fair and
let's go back to what's constitutional
let's go back to what's right because I
frankly don't give a rat's ass as to
what you think is fair anymore do you
think it's fair for conservatives to be
banned from campus and you think it's
fair for people to have safe spaces and
trigger warnings and not pay for the
health care and stay in a plan until
they're 26 years old and get free
college and get free cars I don't care
what you think is fair it doesn't matter
anymore fair means nothing okay speaking
of fair hey Tommy could you do me a
favor real quick could you go in that
corner right there and shut off that
power bar that's what's giving us some
glitches right there underneath yeah
just hit a little light there Tommy so
tomorrow I'll be coming in really soon
[Laughter]
so Fidel Castro died which is a big deal
of course leftist like sold that O'Brien
they were trying well let's look at this
with balance well what's the balance and
a guy who stripped people of their
musical rights that a guy who destroyed
people's privacy rights destroyed a
country that was once unbelievable
people wanted a vacation they're not
saying Batista I'm talking about in in
modern history Fidel Castro is all bad
Che Guevara is all bad at some point
again no matter what's fair well I don't
care what you think me is more complex I
don't care what kind of balance you want
when taking on a story mr. caper Nick
it's fine every now and then to just say
Oh Fidel Castro's dead he's an evil
bastard that's a good thing isn't it
always sad when there's a loss of no no
but don't you nope
isn't that unchristian of you know
you're glad he's dead yep
do you wish it with painful most likely
but we actually well we actually we have
something here do we have them online
okay well here's a segment we were
actually able to get an exclusive with
Fidel Castro from hell so let's let's
let's go to it well good to have this
get let's see how it goes mr. Castro are
you with us
no well huh what do you mean I regret to
inform you that I am no longer with you
okay I see that's very cute
I can see that I can see that Fidel what
have you been up to lately it's what we
want to know no not too much just
hanging around the other day I ran into
my old pal Che Guevara we smoked some
some guys we shoot some necross what I
don't know it did why would you in shape
he shooting people of color you know
they're lazy no I don't know that at all
none of us here a lot it was quite her
understand that at all but I guess that
stands to reason you were a horrible
racist were you surprised at all at your
passing and then your subsequent sort of
landing pad there not so much agnostic I
figure I have a 50/50 shot but as I
smell this offer and I saw Lenin I
figured that makes sense
oh okay right I I see that I only wish
it happened a day earlier was that you
know as a communist dying on Black
Friday I'd say you know Stalin and Lenin
and Mao they never let me live it down
is there is there a lot of hazing that
goes on there in hell
not so much easing but you know
third-degree burns and poker up the yeah
okay now we can't talk this is FCC um I
imagine though it sounds like from what
you're saying then else
I was pretty rough deservedly so made
actually it's very similar to Cuba okay
um how I would didn't want to say this
because I didn't want it but you look
like you're more well-fed you look less
gaunt you know it's surprising what you
can do with access to fresh produce and
you know not at the weight in the food
line
mmm okay yeah I guess that makes sense
and I don't have to fight for the toilet
paper
I had the tax breaks you know what it's
good yeah well I I guess the old wife
not there to complain about my SCOE by
Jared Stephen Jared are you okay
cheered are you okay the whole time okay
sir about that Fidel happens all the
time the other day Soledad O'Brien was
here because she slipped in the tub but
that's terrible is she still alive yeah
she's fine she's knocked out of her coma
after a few days but not after I hear
there's a gar in the old the Betty's bed
early
I mean I'm glad that we're increasing
the quality with the booking of the show
but we people need to be vetted this is
nuts
get dropped so we are we are going to
get in trouble with with CR TV it's a
partnership and they're happy and we're
going daily in January and
[Music]
it really is that simple I I do i do get
sad for a country when we get to a point
in your so that we can disagree on a lot
of things we just talked about that with
Dean Cain I'm sure Tommy Sotomayor and I
disagree on a whole lot but it does
bother me when we get to a point where
an evil son of a [ __ ] dies and you
can't say an evil son of a [ __ ] died I
mean that should be a great unifier
could you imagine when the news came out
they Hitler it as a matter of fact Oh
we'll talk about it Tommy's Donna Meyer
after the break
[Music]
you
I'm now home alone but realistic ladies
and gentlemen of the jury what I ask of
you is not easy I ask that you ignore
the media circus and prior knowledge
regarding the criminal trial as today in
this counter civil suit I intend to
prove to you that the actions on behalf
of one Kevin McAllister were excessive
egregious and cruel use of force which
were both entirely unnecessary and have
no place among civilized society ladies
and gentlemen my clients are guilty of
petty theft that's true trying to feed
their families scraping by and for that
I make no excuses but mr. McAllister
escalated these events hitting my
clients with paint cans
lead pipes tool bags tool chests bricks
shooting them with BB guns electrocuting
them with 12,000 volts of electricity
blowtorching them causing third-degree
burns twice and as previously disclosed
by one of my clients Marv merchant not
being here today
drove a rusty nail through my clients
foot resulting in a subsequent passing
from tetanus and for that behavior we
all should offer no excuse Your Honor
I'd like to call my first witness to the
stand mr. Harry Lime stay tuned from all
home alone but realistic
you don't have to be a doomsday prepper
to want to be prepared natural disaster
riots any kind of civil unrest it just
helps to have peace of mind and know
that if you need it you've got a 30 day
supply of food and that's why right now
with a promotional offer from louder was
Crowder calm you can call eight eight
eight four five seven three four five
three or go to prepare with CR calm
that's eight eight eight four five seven
three four five three or go to prepare
with CR calm you can get your 30-day
full supply of food set it somewhere
forget about at $99 shipped 140 servings
that's a it's easy I just keep it in my
basement and it's actually I tried some
of my wife it's pretty good it's tasty
stuff oh yeah they're chocolate pudding
is it's actually really pretty tasty how
are you breathing with that
[Music]
[Music]
all right we are glad to have our next
guest on he's here in studio this is a
rarity
Tommy sitting right now what's what's
the best plug for you is that your
Twitter is it your YouTube a flag it
down one second Hong second are we do we
have us mic in not gey Jarrod can they
hear him because I can't hear him today
hear him what he just said
I can't hear him can you hear now
Courtney can't hear him there we go all
right
I think he's not now is he on now not
gay jeer it is the unknown Oh Courtney
can you hear him as long as you can
check in your levels there this is a
disaster first night we don't even have
the right sign as long as Jared tells me
I'm trusting Jared that he's good to go
all right what's your best plug sorry
Tommy I'm probably twitter at TJ's open
my you'll add TJ Sotomayor and he's got
some he's got some Grand Marnier there I
got the Grand Moff when I asked him I
asked him my idea what's your drink of
choice like no no and then I don't I
think he thought we were too cheap to
have Grand Marnier here in the in the
cabinet
yeah he had very low expectations well
we appreciate you being here so you do a
lot you do a lot on the youtubes you do
a lot online and a lot of people don't
like you know mainly black people I've
had a bunch of white guys coming at me
lately they're guilty white people I
know and that's why we got the shirts on
the website called guiltless I love the
plug - he's plugging it out there
shameless um okay so first off did you
vote in this election yes I did did you
vote for who do you vote for Trump there
you go did you lose friends and
relatives over the I lost relatives that
I was financially compensating in the
first place so they came back afternoon
oh really
hey it was one of those things where
yeah they were upset for a little while
strange though you had people really
going against each other because of
ideologies right and most of the parties
who were having the biggest problem
Democrats
yeah well the main people who want you
to accept their ideologist yeah and that
I want
well it is ironic but it's it's not this
isn't an Alanis Morissette song so we
don't need we get the irony I don't
think she understood irony sometimes in
that song it's like no atlanta's that's
not irony that's coincidence dumb broad
irony he is like I need to buy an anvil
and you die by an anvil
you know coincidence it's like oh oh
this happened we both happen to be here
isn't that ironic no it's not people
must use it all the time also like the
term literally so yes did you vote for
Donald Trump and we were talking like
this so you were just how about this off
air now there's a protest in North
Carolina with Keith Scott it just seems
like it we're at a point where we are so
damned if we do and damned if we don't
and do you feel like with Barack Obama
another transition to Donald Trump
that baton passing is going to be worse
than ever before
well I think what happened is we had
eight years of not being able to
honestly criticize a president right so
now you're gonna have one that's gonna
be overly criticized because for eight
years they haven't been able to say
anything so now it's emissions let me
think about it there were so many things
that people would normally say about a
president that you couldn't say about
Barack Obama because if you said it you
were racist yes that is true and under
some people who were actually racist
like not gay Jared you should hear what
he says when you you didn't have the
headphones in exact horrible I just saw
the faces he was cutting holes and
sheets Jared you should be ashamed of
yourself that's my bad so the Keith
Scott situation black cops on a black
guy it seems like they found a gun here
and you so you talk about this a lot on
your show what is the reaction been with
with that one here's one thing I will
say about that okay as and you can
correct me if I'm just culturally
incentives I know of some people who are
who are out of touch with black American
culture not myself and Grand Marnier we
got Hennessy there this is the first
thing he offered me was 45 well no there
was no liquor like you need do you want
some Mickey's there brother no so um I
watch it and I watch this tape of the
woman now it's revealed of the guy did
have a gun you know that tape came out
but I hear the wife and she just said he
better not be there he better not be
dead talking to the cops when she thinks
her husband was a shot now for my wife
she'd be just she'd be crying she would
be out of her mind she'd be really sad
this woman seemed to Dignan just like
she was there to piss off cops it is
that is that is that typical or did you
watch that and think that was weird as
well no no running me and my mom
I mean it was pretty much any random
black chick off the planets I mean I'm
sorry that is just remember the woman
who got her husband shot in Minnesota or
her Bob the kid's father in Minnesota
yeah she went live on Facebook and was
talking the exact same way he was still
breathing she said you killed my
boyfriend Yeah right like white women
will try to take you from do not go
towards the light
right like she's pushing you towards the
light it was weird what's a black light
yeah and apparently but but in like all
kinds of stuff show up but it that's me
I can feel your teeth but if you think
about it like well from my perspective
it was not abnormal to see these women
turn the spotlight to themselves yeah
but what really bothered me about her
situation is she said he doesn't even
own a gun and they went back and found
that eight months prior
what did she go to the police and say
he's been threatening me with a gun she
asked for a restraining order and it was
for the exact gun that they found them
but maybe that's why she's not so upset
maybe that's why he better not be dead
oh I hope he did he the worst one too
was uh well the worst one was corn
Gaines but we had that that was so much
material for this show because I mean I
know it's sad again when everyone dies
but it's not always no it's not first
off when you cut that out yes yes
sometimes what first off death is
inevitable yeah and sometimes it came
just right in town because you don't
think about that kid that kid is gonna
have to grow up in a house with an
eating well that's true but I also think
you aim a loaded shotgun at cops you
can't you kind of have death on
speed-dial you know they're in your top
five yeah as it were
you have rollover minutes with death
dominoes and probably yes okay so what's
your take here in Keith Scott now
because like you said they're rioting
over this is you're gonna we're gonna
hit a point do you think where there are
people like you people like my friends
no Alphonso a Jew larry elder who on the
show it seemed like more black people
are willing to speak up do you think
there are more black people who think
the way you do and are afraid and now
they'll be less afraid or do you think
it's still you know
that gotten that the Democrats have got
to by the short hairs well once you
offer someone something that they don't
really have to work for it's kind of
hard to lose that fan base yeah that's
right and when they do it's like
Metallica doesn't matter what they do
it's just here for everything post the
st. anger and people like Larry Elder
myself the things you have to worry
about is for some reason the
name-calling means a lot you know I I
quit black people to like Marty McFly
blacks it back to the future okay like
I'll go with you just say hey will
you're you yellow your chicken yeah
we'll stop so what we get called is a
[ __ ] or a sellout and we'll stop and
that is so powerful in the black
community the names where is the term
for sale I thought [ __ ] was more of a
racist term against blacks from like
just an instance it used to be but black
people would want to feel there's a
whole psychology behind it black people
want to be white people so the best way
to be white people is to adat well why
would they want to be white people
well why people have been in power and
black people would like to be in power
if you think about it
blacks believe that whites are
oppressive to them because of their skin
color people in the black community one
of the main things that black people do
to other blacks is pick on them because
of their skin color there's a guy who
was on Tucker Carlson dr. Tyree's
machine has a puppet aimed at me making
fun of me call crispy crispy is saying
I'm so black that it's on a track but
here's a puppet yeah there's a whole
puppet series is it funny no I don't
think it's funny you know coming from a
guy that says melanin is magic right and
he calls you crispy yeah and he has a
whole series of how I'm black in the
bean black is ugly
well well no but puppets can be
remarkably funny no they are we wanted
to get a roger ailes puppet who would
just Pierre and the lady's skirts
whenever they're on the show but HR
wouldn't allow it and and and and that's
saying because I would like to see ya
know yes by HR I mean not gay Jared said
he would file a sexual harassment
lawsuit hey it works we're gonna have
you I want to roll this clip here so if
you can hear you can hear your stuff in
your earphones now right myself okay you
can hear yourself can you hear okay he
can hear the program right now Kate here
this clip happened on CNN and it
so it was a gift when I knew that you
were gonna be on the show this week we
have two clips right let's roll the
first clip here where someone was
quoting someone else falsely by the way
was a liberal trying to quote a
conservative and well let's just watch
the clip here Tommy Jews as a White
House counselor counselor a man who uses
the word [ __ ] whose wife says that he
did not want his daughters to go to a
school with too many Jews and don't
choose as an attorney general man who
calls the n-double-a-cp a nun American
organization and who we learned in The
Guardian today went so far as the
plastic okay just hang on a second I
appreciate you going through all of this
but please don't use the n-word
on my show I'm sorry well I've never
used the n-word except when I'm quoting
someone who's been appointed by the
President to serve in the Oval Office
since this is such a disgusting moment
nor his look at that face okay now you
would think that would end there now
first off I have to ask promote were you
offended by that guy I'm gonna quote he
was trying to coach Steve Bannon and he
didn't use it he's a liberal trying to
quote a conservative who didn't use the
word but she didn't know it really at
the time so it's just funny the virtue
signalling from the white woman but
here's where it gets really good at the
end of the show she still can't let it
go watch I'm still the more I've sat
here and listened to the fact that
somebody use the n-word on this show it
is not okay it is not okay Charles
Kaiser or respect you I enjoy having you
wanted to guess but uh
not okay by the way do you think that's
genuine or do you think that's just her
like trying to go for the ratings I'm
assuming they should have put some
pearls on her so she could have
questioned understanding how she has
such indignation I know but it's not
been this bad before when I was being
raised you know just email I wonder if
it's kind of like the death throes right
now with liberals I mean or broadcasters
the terms are synonymous at this point
as they move toward Trump to tribe like
we are just so offended by everything
because they want to set the stage for
being extra offended by Donald Trump but
I don't know I watched that now was
going well you know what again maybe on
the white guy I'm out of touch but it
just seems so silly to me to she acted
like it was reverberating through her
soul well and that's the problem with it
the problem with white
people are white liberals and white
guilt yeah this idea that you can be so
offended by a word more than the guy the
black guy was sitting there just waiting
on the next point yeah okay where's he's
trying to go with it right
he wasn't offended by it but this woman
was like oh my god someone give me my
oxygen back because I just lost it all
yeah and then later in the segment to be
crying about it or falsely as you said
it's virtual signaling but what it
really is is everybody in this effort to
make sure that they're overly
sympathetic towards the black cause
because you got to remember right there
white people who if they don't seem
sympathetic when someone says something
they're fired that's true losing that
job yeah so if she knows this was said
on the show she doesn't know the tip the
tenor of the people watching yeah so
it's best for her to go over to your
left then look like she's just letting
the interview because they're gonna say
well you were you were enjoying it as
well yes Jeff Zucker might walk in and
go um
listen let me speak with you sweetheart
when that young man said the n-word you
did not display enough outrage we're
going to replace he was sold at O'Brien
that's right also you're not attractive
enough we need to compete with Fox News
doesn't give you seen her this week when
she was doing the apology tour for Fidel
Castro no now are you are you aware
though by the way that Che Guevara and
Fidel Castro were notorious racists are
you aware of that history that they I
heard this somewhere but I'm not you
probably heard from Fidel from hell
that's probably where you heard it
before
ya know Che Guevara hated black people
and wanted to be that pure blood
European pure blood Spanish European he
did he believed they were lazy he
believed they were incompetent he
believed they were a drain on the work
force and so there were a
disproportionately large amount of black
people executed in Cuba without trial
under Che Guevera and then of course
Castro they were buddies and most people
don't know that's when they were the Che
Guevara t-shirt
it literally is supporting a racial
genocide estat so worse actually
no it's horrible yeah how can you I
don't understand how you can live as a
black man in 2016 and not know about the
mass I just
was kind of a big one I think you're
gonna unzip himself and it's gonna be
like hey it's me Val Kilmer I was a
callback to Dean Cain which you couldn't
hear earlier okay we're gonna come back
with you what's your YouTube channel my
youtube channel is Tommy Sotomayor
Tommy's son of mine a great stuff we
love it and he has a lot of championship
belts I don't know where he gets it for
because I win them from people like you
who can't debate people like me I'm
drinking to that well I think it's
because he's black and they box a lot
[Music]
we have created a product that is the
most deliberate middle finger to the
media establishment ever designed
ceramic to tempt with a child rim and
hand edge to finish this product grants
those who wielded entry into the most
exclusive club in all the universe
aluminum for louder with crowd and MA
Club will change the way you view the
world where possibilities are now
endless Burberry's a distant memory and
hashtag never daily transforms into a
new daily program fish and chips with
Steven is free to be unfiltered
uncensored and even capable of gross
abuses of the FCC guidelines and not gay
Jared's physical body on live broadcast
proudly introducing the mud I'm
narrating something fancy like I'm nari
proudly introduce the new daily program
the louder was crowd and Mugler aims to
elevate the human experience distracting
one joining now I know commercial
[Music]
tell me soon am i right yes twitter is
TJ Sotomayor yep okay so you want to
talk about before Liz you had an
interesting point about women voting in
this election that wasn't you said okay
what's the percentage of black women who
voted for ninety six percent they said
was 96 between 96 98 percent of all
black women voted for Hillary Clinton
a white woman right but white women who
were basically being forced by the
liberal media mhm
to vote for Hillary Clinton we're
shattering the glass ceiling if you're a
woman and you don't want to vote for cuz
they were making ridiculous arguments
about Donald Trump he's a sexist he's a
racist and then they started coming up
with names I'd never heard of well
you've given me some niggly peg was
morning I never heard of that a [ __ ] Li
bear they're bears so bears black geeky
about niggly bear I was like see I have
the card to be able to do that I'm a
black guy so I just say what I want it's
a great part about it's true I got you
can Punk white people and they'll just
do what you want yeah well my dog you
met my dog that was a black guy try to
steal him out there in Oklahoma when I
was driving Choctaw casino who talked
about that he was like that's my dog I
think no and he was about ready to fight
and I just want to put the dog in the
car and I walked back up yeah well it is
a beautiful dog I was trying to figure
out a way I can whiteboard punk you know
yeah I've just been looking around
trying to figure out what I can Punk you
out of well
and you can take that home but be
careful when the cops pull you over
okay so so black women voting yeah okay
but then yeah on the flip side but on
the flip side white women who were
basically being forced didn't do it
matter of fact 56 percent of white women
voted for Donald Trump the sexist the
racist you know and it was strange that
the women would actually and I'm
wondering what your opinion on this why
do you think white women turned away
from the quote-unquote first white woman
because when we got an opportunity for
the first black guy yeah we voted for
him on Moss yeah she's a [ __ ] no I
realize she's such an unlikable person
but why were they able to notice this
the white women were able to say it
doesn't matter that she's a woman she's
a [ __ ] so we don't want her there cuz
black people didn't care about what
Barack Obama's policies were right it
was just that he's black yeah no I think
you're right there-there is that I mean
I can understand that as well you know
no I voted for him the first time
because I wanted a black guy did you go
from Romney the second time yes really
there's no whiter candidate than Minh
Truong I know that's why I like wrote
for a real n-word you before you say it
just has to bleep it well but I was like
this is a real white like when he said
47% I which I don't understand how that
was ever offensive but that's where
we've gotten with the Liberals telling
the truth is you're tantamount to
treason yeah no it's a good point 47% of
people don't pay federal income tax and
their vote matters just as much as you
and I and the the real sad thing
actually with that is that the racism of
soft expectations if you notice what
they did with Romney with the 47% they
immediately were trumpeting that to the
black community the Latino community
like see cuz they assume like people
don't pay taxes black people don't work
they assume this is a Lyndon Johnson
sort of syndrome right they assume that
well you need us to help you and so
that's what's so interesting to me about
that is I know I know you pay taxes a
man I we've seen your channel every
pretty she's gonna be a Willie Nelson
we're all gonna have to do a sing-along
a concert - lets pay TJ soda Myers back
taxes knocking Jarrett he's just been he
doesn't pay his taxes just because he
likes the prison sex what
so I I walked into I want you know what
you walk into his that liquid crack in
the buckets well no so it was
interesting to me that right away they
pivoted and this is again as an ignorant
white person just like well gosh that's
just horrible they take that and they
assume that it's boring people aren't
paying taxes they assume that they're
incapable of doing it and they assume
they'll hate Mitt Romney actually I do I
do like Mitt Romney probably more than
than Donald Trump in a lot of ways yes
he really you too yep
so if you choose either to his president
you pick wrong Mitt Romney yes oh my
gosh you're gonna get letters oh I have
said it several times yeah why's that
don't open those letters snake cyanide
don't do it but the reason why is
because he seems like more of a
practical president he seems like he
uses logic and I'm a big logic guy yeah
and the fact is his business experience
to me is more practical when it comes to
cuz both are supposed to be business
guys right but I look at one and the way
he handles business and he's not all
about being brash and cuz a lot of what
Donald Trump does is just for flash yuck
right now he's come back after we voted
him in for certain things and said well
I'm not actually gonna do that which I
understand playing politics and being a
politician is two different things right
but you have to understand Mitt Romney
was not giving us that he was trying to
give us more practical things that he
was going to try and implement if he was
to become president it was a clean up
guy a member when he was running to live
at Bain Capital he just basically came
in and downsize and laid people off
house going yeah that's what you want in
the government right just come in chop
some stuff off lay them off that's kind
of my issue with Donald I'm like the
three trillion spending that they're
talking about it's like well I opposed
it when Barack Obama did this crazy
deficit spending I opposed it now
hopefully he'll come to his senses and
and hopefully I just my one hope here is
that regardless black white male female
that we can support him where he's right
and criticize him when he's wrong and
not lose you know half the audience
because they claim that you're in the
tank one way or the other image which is
every week right depending on your
opinion so what do you think about what
happened in Indianapolis good or bad
where we talk about in the endless
I'm not trained it's not trained it's
the air-conditioned factory oh yeah well
we were talking with the earlier in the
program
it depends here's the thing I'm all for
incentivizing people right to bring jobs
back to America but here's the truth
made in America isn't necessarily a sign
of quality it can sometimes be a sign of
crap made by big unions you know what I
mean so I want people to make it in
America I want you to be American and by
the best and I want to get to the point
where America is making the best you
know a good example I always use is
Harley back in the AMF days they were
horrible motorcycles and so we put
tariffs on Honda's and in Yamaha is
coming in this was actually under Reagan
because they were much better than
Harley and what did that do we had a gas
crisis before that it just made it
harder for everyday Americans to get to
work right so my opinion is lower the
corporate tax code make it business
friendly but I don't want to see people
like punish businesses to keep their
doors open by outsourcing do you not
fear that companies though we're
watching this would start to hold the
American government hostage I do that's
my biggest fear when I saw that I said
well if I'm a company I'm gonna say well
I'm gonna ship my stuff overseas unless
you give me something and that's what it
looked like was gonna happen yeah I
think you're right ah well you can stick
around actually because we have two
chairs and we're gonna have Courtney
cube job coming up at Courtney's gust at
TJ Sotomayor youtube.com slash Tommy so
Tamara thank you sir we'll keep you
around stay tuned or you're racist
[Music]
hey NOC gauge here I know people are
watching this on YouTube but we're kin
the go if they want to watch louder with
Conor Daly and gain access to all of CRT
B's programming letter of credit I comm
slush mug Club and how much does it cost
now I know it's annually for a 69 for
students veteran or military $69 multi
from a quote military active military
don't forget that it's a good deal what
did you turn them jacuzzi
hey Jared what are you doing shooting
bad guys with what - where'd you get it
yeah 50 NOK I need it more clearly so
our audience can hear ar-15 dot-com
that's better
they sell guns now yeah they do are they
any good - the best
we're from there 15 accom Kapoor come on
you really make that sound didn't have
the budget for sound effects with 150
from well here 15 accom how do you know
they're bad guys Debra's in burkas
that's racist
[Music]
see see Tommy can't help himself from
singing when he gets in not so he said
I'm on the way do we have her theme song
here today don't have a theme song ha ha
all a new set up ok but we have the
audio working out like Dean Cain alright
so you know her you love her she's one
of the best writers I've ever in Canada
shut up ever encountered in my life at
Courtney scoffs you know her
Courtney tear Chavez the first time look
at her in studio they said we met for
the first time recently it was look at
how lovely Courtney looks now here's the
worst part as you're going to get
criticism from people who don't like you
for your worldview and the compliments
you get are going to be equally
upsetting just do the creepy factor
that's why I don't read them so Tommy's
laughing because he knows it's true he
knows it's true people are looking a
look at the gams great gams by the way
thank you she was a gutter anywhere near
here you'd see my mind that was actually
a pretty nice compliment what my
appearance made his mind go into the
gutter yeah that's actually not bad he
wouldn't probably say it about Amy
Schumer no he wouldn't say about Amy
Schumer because she's very unattractive
Wow yeah so okay so we have Courtney and
she doesn't she doesn't know here's the
thing she's earned it she unlike Amy
Schumer who just tosses on an old navy
scarf and sits in a Pirelli calendar
which by the way used to think rhetoric
shouldn't happen she hasn't earned on
Courtney does all the lifting in the
crop what's your squad up to Courtney
253 oh good lord
you could that's that's to Backstreet
Boys so okay you can hurt me she won't
that's nuts
why do you use yourself as any kind of a
litmus test this is true that's like
saying I don't thing for thing to do
probably put you over my head can we do
that can we set that up and we get her
in flats I just figured a rad thing
could be said but I would need my
lifting shoes which I left at home it
okay so what I'm just talking about the
about the female vote no less but you
were you wanted to talk about these um
the reality show people I was talking
about this I touched on it earlier this
we have okay
inform the audience for those who don't
know okay so chip and Joanna Gaines are
in Waco Texas and they have an immensely
popular show an HD HGTV called
fixer-upper and they renovate homes okay
that's that's what they do sometimes pop
it was a show but go well no but
they tear things down they get excited
about things like shiplap and tearing
down a house what shiplap I
it's beautiful it's not vertical pain
when it's horizontal family okay yeah
well that's really trendy yeah yeah well
because one of the reasons because of
the show mm-hmm these these people
they're wonderful people they've got
four kids and I speak farm there are
multi racial I guess family and they've
just now had their fourth season
premiering it's been very successful
what is the multi racial mean
interracial oh okay multiracial is this
panel interracial is well we only have
we only have two races here I guess
that's that's multi racial yeah
interracial maybe you would think that
would term Tommy an interracial is it
multiracial I don't know I'm not
involved in any of it but I would assume
that multiracial just means like your
many races and just interracial has
something to do with where if they're
doing something together okay pick all
right go ahead I'll let you finish
Courtney anyway so why what I wanted to
know is why now mm-hmm it was an obvious
witch-hunt BuzzFeed is going after them
yet we know that there's a war on the
religious right yeah and if you don't
conform you shall be yeah yeah I think
it's a record show that she did it she
didn't decapitate it no mess though well
if I you know if I had my theme song and
Darth Vader I could have done that would
have been good why do you have to choke
the black guy continue well I would have
done you but would you bring a noose
while you're at it I'm dragging behind a
truck gosh I just said you got to be
careful when you're tall and blond
there's less forgiveness I could take
off you know so I have somewhat of a
pass why cuz you're I don't know that is
they send me pictures of manic they ass
up and it's horrible okay go ahead
anyway ben shapiro knows this that's why
we have a kinship go ahead continue
anyway uh I think there at BuzzFeed was
going after yeah the religion but there
maybe this is the wrong term
heteronormative yeah uh they're just
immensely successful or they're a
nuclear family they're living the
American dream
everybody likes them so BuzzFeed's like
well we gotta take them out yeah and
well BuzzFeed is done and then of course
the media followed suit the whole know
what's interesting was
the left kind of double down on BuzzFeed
ins that this isn't obvious witch hunt
this is a terrible thing to do you're
proving Donald Trump voters O'Reilly
yeah okay so it was almost damage
control because we've seen that well the
pastor salon didn't do that they must
have jumped in on it I don't yeah salon
is where Tommy's mind is that's where
you'll find it when you walk in in the
dress but I'm 32 so if I was 16 maybe 8
yeah see I'm 40 so you know so more
thinking so long pause but go ahead okay
so so this happened and you wanted to
contrasting that with with the OSU
attacker who is a Muslim yeah is that
Isis fanboy and I assistance his death
has taken him in as their own and the
media is saying the opposite oh no it
wasn't his religious views we should we
should keep an open mind we don't really
know yet why he did it
like no he did it cuz he's is Lama stand
he hates this country so they're fine
with excusing like and war I think it's
his name it's hard to pronounce yeah who
took a kitchen knife and saw saute
people sliced and diced mmm we can saute
with a kitchen knife it's not hot enough
well that's what he used the
undercarriage of his car - all right
yeah the word undercarriage yeah so am i
yeah I don't like it I think like I'm a
boxer in turn undercarriage we can say
for home go home okay so that is a good
contrast to talk about that it said not
all Muslims right we're talking about
yeah they say not all Muslims and then
they take the hit on chip and Joanna
wasn't even then they they weren't even
available for comment they went to find
out what their church pastor said about
it
it was a very long travursel even is
really reached we'll see that's the
thing go into any Christian Church pick
a denomination and and tell me which one
doesn't follow the biblical teaching on
marriage Episcopalians never meant to be
you meant that to be rhetorical don't
marry anyone Episcopalians even a
pedophile from so on
another problem with it Unitarians as
well but I don't really like a club
yeah don't have a religion yeah but or
not it's like a Rotary Club for people
who want to sing hymns but they want
they want the community yeah but not the
belief what you write about this a lot
and it obviously gets you know gets lost
in the mix when you have the people
saying oh the Christian writers
persecuted because the Starbucks cup
lost snowflakes and we agreed how silly
that was so stupid
but these witch hunts occurred but not
long ago they wouldn't have been
considered witch hunts I mean you would
lose your job if you went to it Church
I'm not if you're Barack Obama in here
you know your pastor Oh see that's the
other thing okay eight years ago
chickens come home to roost
we the media say media who's going after
chip and Joanna they're like oh it
doesn't matter what the pastor said like
Barack Obama doesn't believe that yeah
he doesn't believe that was it reven
Wright reven Wright says yeah so eight
years later this lovely little couple
who's making their dream come true by
building up other people's houses giving
people houses you're gonna take these
people down yeah for something that
their pastor said that that most of
America believes yeah a significant well
I don't have most of America but it's
Navin portion of them or they at least
believe that pastors or churches
shouldn't have to marry you know to guys
if they don't want to yeah and when you
when you have someone who took a butcher
knife kitchen knife and tried to stab
people and then the meat is like oh no
it wasn't Islam and then the same week
Chip and Joanna we got to get rid of
them because yeah they think you know
they go to a church where marriage is
between one man horn I was more offended
that the OSU attacker was trying to get
the student discount how do you get bald
at 19 well hon
Tommy soon wearing a hat so we don't
know an eye nurse at but I'm saying we
don't know what's under there yes can
you grow hair no space broke up you can
stick it in the back there's a big hole
there okay so I'm sorry and Rogaine
doesn't work does it not work no gosh
well I love that you get your money back
because there's 30 day they will give it
back they were like oh your hairs
different
two weeks later the infomercial broke in
black there's longer sir were missing
Johnson
but I mean what is this guy that was I
know Daily Mail was reporting on it I
wasn't confirmed but they were like he
seemed a lot older well some of the
refugees over in Europe like oh no he's
14 no yeah exactly if he's 14 and I'm 13
and now we're back to salon right I
don't like my 14 year olds in Sweden
must be really effective rapists yeah
so I think the only way to solve it with
refugees - with Islamic refugees who are
rapists you know who we see in these
countries who come in record numbers the
only way to stall their ages is like
trees you have to saw them in half and
look at the Rings yeah I think that's
one we have to do it it is because he's
he's Islamic yeah I know
but do you rape somebody so I think it's
okay I think it's a you know but it's a
cultural difference if you don't like
their culture women are second class and
so he brings that over here and we
should kind of accommodate to him and
and and in solidarity what isn't that
CNN who was saying that we should wear
hijabs the trap you wrote about I don't
think I did publication publication what
about it yes CNN did you see this Tommy
they said we should be to show support
for Muslims yeah you don't wear hijabs
incidentally and Islam marriages between
a man and women this is true yeah yeah
it is well as many women as he wants
yeah and you can hit them just but if
it's for a good reason
you sure you have to have cause only
lightly to just light you can't cause
bruising where people would see it but
when they're dressed like ninjas that's
it's a shocker isn't it that's why crows
in prison yeah it only grows by breeding
and prison
and they're like it's the fastest cause
in prison you have my Dyson come in and
I'm just so angry here's a book that
says how to hate I'm deaf okay I forget
this I'm gonna be a Muslim this thing
comes out with the Jehovah's Witnesses
come to your door and they try to give
you the the Kingdom Hall pamphlet you're
like no no thanks I'm good and Islam
they're like well if you don't do this
[Laughter]
last week like you said it's been really
good hopefully to highlight this where
people anyone who's actually followed
those stories right with these people in
the reality show and and then a
subsequent follow-up with the OSU
situation I'm hoping it opens more
I'm hoping I think but I think a lot of
the liberal media are worried about it
and so they're kind of trying to do
damage control on yeah okay back up back
up we can't do this this is why we lost
right even people like Bernie Sanders
like you can't you can't tell people who
voted Trump that they're a bunch of
racist but then but then Bernie Sanders
calls them a bunch of racists yeah he's
the new white supremacist here oh yes
okay we talked about that after the
break times I find that absolutely
hysterical Bernie Sanders is now a
card-carrying a Klansman according to
someone I don't have my computer with me
but we can bring it up later we wrote
about this Courtney Kerr Chavan Tommy
Sotomayor in studio if you leave your
racist and sexist
[Music]
hey no you're enjoying this weekly show
on YouTube or iTunes and it'll always be
free don't worry but if you want to
support the fight to take media back and
watch louder with Crowder daily and get
access to all of CR t v--'s programming
including Mark Levin Mark Steyn Michelle
Malkin and more subscribe at ladder with
Qatar dot-com slash mug Club for 99
dollars annually 69 dollars for students
entering promo code student hey Matt
gage Sharon have you joined the mug club
yet No
[Music]
[Music]
got to be back at Courtney scoffs we
were talking about this you I need the
computers it's okay to not have
everything in writing she's a right
she's right I need to read the words a
writer minded person no this happened
Bernie Sanders some left us for coming
out in their mad saying that he was an
example of white supremacy and then
people hold on hold on let's wait and
they just the infighting the
cannibalization of the left and knows no
bounds they're they're panicking cuz
they if they lost and they it wasn't a
landslide loss
no no landslide loss and always the
people don't need to overestimate the
influence someone like Trump has right
now yeah right so they're they're in a
bit of a panic and they're there's a lot
of infighting going on and I think it's
delightful it's yes Christmas well you
want to join I know so this is a good
example of what changed when we were
watching an election and I said I never
wanted to go to fahren because we didn't
know how we would feel right right to a
lot of code I think almost everybody
held their nose kind of voted Republican
down the ticket but we weren't Trump
people in the in the primaries no I mean
all of election day we were kind of
miserable like oh yeah all right choices
I can't believe this it's the worst
but then the reaction from the left and
you enjoyed it so much where I was
traveling and you were like just I got I
I'm going to handle the site because I
can't get enough of it we didn't have
enough time slot stuff just kept coming
in and it was okay for the first post
like I don't know should I do it basic
summary of everything that's gone wrong
yes let's do some hits on the media
having epic meltdowns
yeah I like to use the word epic but it
it was absolutely a fall dude is it just
me and maybe both of you can chime in
here is it just me or was was this
behavior the most childish that we've
seen from the left ER has it always been
that way and we just didn't have social
media to see it I think they've always
been it's always been that way but
they've been able to mask it behind
blaming the other side
riki right before the election it was a
foregone conclusion that Hillary Clinton
was gonna win yeah so they were setting
it up saying and make sure you don't
challenge the election and handle it
like grown people and yeah and then they
were the one that's true and that was
amazing and stuff to what you were
talking about I just find it odd that
the Ohio State guy you can't say
anything about him being a Muslim you
can't tie it to being a Muslim but
almost every time a white person does
something to a black person no matter
what the circus
he's racist right wasn't there something
with the cop to an LSU where people were
mad at him was that what happened yes
yeah that's right a guy I camera his
name on Twitter but he's short
several million brain cells same tarik
machine yes bad guy oh I'm saying but
now that you said he was a puppet of
time or not oh is that the same guy yeah
call crispy okay all right he's good
hidden colors because of course blacks
are hidden I don't know that you should
bleep drive their operating machinery no
IIIi don't shouldn't be on a panel with
Tucker Carlson which is fun it's Tucker
Carlson was never thought of as a really
formidable opponent remember you know
Jon Stewart kind of embarrassed him back
in the day and now it's just it's just
like shooting fish in a barrel because
they buy nuclear warhead every time
every time I see Tucker Carlson like
that guy I I
he's like my hero it's cuz he's one of
the only people on Fox who brings on
opposing viewpoints and actually gives
him you lied about it
he doesn't raise his voice he'll just
say wow you're just really wrong yeah
and dish the bowtie which is big he had
the bowtie for the entire yeah he was on
CNN crossfire with Paul Begala and he
just had he had a bow tie all the time
that was his gimmick to me that was
always the bow tie
so I think he's kind of this is like
refreshed Tucker Carlson I like it but
one thing we've talked about this in
Courtney and I we've talked about this
I'm sure Tommy you're aware of it
basically being independent media and
and Jared knows we did a segment on it
that went kind of viral and now
everyone's talking about the echo
chambers that are created with media you
stand at Vox
and New York Times and we talked about
this the to sort of world we have
someone who has a mom who loves Donald
Trump she likes the page on Facebook and
Twitter and YouTube and then someone who
likes Hillary Clinton in six months in
there just getting feeds reiterating
what they want to hear and so it really
does worth what we do with our site a
lot of times the reason I think we're
relatively successful is most of our
stories come from leftist sites right we
run it down it's huff poets along still
like we go what are they saying and how
do we inform people as they are you
against us yeah exactly I don't think
you see a lot of people doing that
certainly not on the left because if
you're a conservative if you're on the
right or certainly like as a black
conservative right you've been hearing
their arguments forever and it's so rare
for them to hear this kind of a
conversation that they're not prepared
for it no I need sometimes
don't even understand nuance or senses
of humor yeah
so it's true I read a while ago like a
hit piece on was Milo they were talking
about my own oh I can't believe you said
this and I wouldn't i watch the clip he
was telling a joke
yeah and I thought he was serious and I
and he had even said like look I if I
can't if people don't understand humor
what was the joke you remember I can't
it was something now I'm sorry the
punchline so that's better than ruining
it um yeah you know it's funny I've had
that too I remember when I was at Cal
Poly and there was black lives matter
there with their phones like this in
solidarity and they were fact-checking
my jokes
they were like jokes people yeah I know
that ain't true in my book you're right
it's not well you have to understand no
a lot of liberals I found that out I
thought they were supposed to be the
educated people and maybe they are but
they don't understand something called
sarcasm yeah you noticed you came out so
which is funny because they tryna act
like it's convenient yes sarcasm like
Fidel Castro it's about the nuance and
that complexity
yes mrs. O'Brien oh who knows why you
can made it to mass murder no one knows
but he did brown the country a little
bit you know he did round the country
but he unwell but he used to end him on
blacked the country Tommy wasn't aware
of this the literacy rate wasn't the
literacy rate pretty good and that's all
that matters intentions yeah I I suppose
I don't know I mean I don't know who's
reporting these rates it's like that's
right or they're like our crimes at an
all-time low yeah yeah all of our people
can read they can't eat they can't eat
they have no toilet thing they could
read the cereal box if one was given to
them okay this is a good question what
are your opinions here on the
relationships with Cuba you know the so
you have Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz coming
out these people saying like no we
really shouldn't have a working
relationship with you with Cuba until
they treat their civilians fairly and
give them basic human rights and then
you have the mindset of Barack Obama and
even some conservatives saying well we
don't wanna be isolationist so we should
reach out to them should we be
conducting business should we be
allowing Americans to go to places where
these people don't even have basic
fundamental human rights or is it not
our business and
people go wherever they want well you
either open it up to everybody or you
close it to everybody because China has
a one-child policy or at least I believe
they turn to proposed it here in the
states I was there too climate some that
you know I saw there they're taking them
and and sometimes just removing their
second children's yeah third but turn
over a product and that's made in China
this is true so where do we draw the
line what do you think time do you think
we should be engaging in business trade
with with with Cuba urges or now I think
you should always engage people because
just that engagement of those people
will make it a lot easier for you to
maybe understand them didn't understand
you yeah and you start exporting
American ideas yeah it's pretty hard
though when you go because all the money
goes to the top that's the challenge the
people can't get to hear it I actually
have a story about that in Havana with
my mother when we went and we shot a
rising crust pizza commercial when I was
in high school I was in Havana
I almost got mugged this is true but
there's there's more to it than that
involves lipstick watch
[Music]
do you have fire alarms in your house
about fire extinguishers locks on your
door light switches of course you do
because you're prepared gentlemen or
woman or gentle Z we want to be gender
neutral here but a lot of you could be
in some kind of danger if there's a
natural disaster riot something for
which you're not prepared I had the ice
storm in Montreal for over seven days no
food water or power doesn't need to be a
cataclysmic event can be something that
people face every day across this
country and that's why right now with a
promo with prepare with CR calm or you
can call eight eight eight four five
seven three four five three to get your
30-day supply emergency kit that's a
hundred and forty servings for $99 ship
this is a special offer it's not going
on forever $99 shipped 30-day food
supply just register over there at
that's right prepare with CR dot-com or
888 four five seven three four five
three I was distracted by my my friend
here
[Music]
too strong
alright let it be back my Cuba story
really quickly then we'll get to you not
now so I was in Cuba and this is true we
were they were shooting rising crust
pizza commercial the studio had to run
out their budget and I was a kid and I
didn't need to go to Cuba long story
short you know you're supposed to bring
things there for them like makeup
Chiclets is a big thing like gum things
that they don't have there my mom
accidentally we were in Havana put a tip
on the bill I said mom they're not gonna
they're not gonna get the tip and put in
the bill sake oh I'm sorry I'm so she
goes excuse me will you get the tip if I
put it on the bill she's like no she's
okay she got stew scratched out and like
panicked like they were gonna lock her
in a closet for days on end because they
would know if it was scratched out that
she had told them she doesn't get the
tip so people don't understand how I
mean this was in 2004 just how cruel of
a regime the Castro regime let me
imagine there's a special place in hell
for someone who punishes somebody simply
for actually following the rules and
saying well actually I don't get the tip
so don't put it on the bill that's crazy
no geez this is not right I'm sorry
you know this is because we have a dark
man I was about to say okay so we were
talk about the CNN clip with Haman you
had you had something to say on that it
was a good good point
yeah the if you're outraged if you're
outraged by something that doesn't make
you a better person
sure makes you an idiot it makes you you
know you don't have control of your
emotions there's this thing right now in
the outreach culture if you get really
offended by something or because you
care so much that just makes you a
better person
it doesn't yeah your feelings do not
make you a better person what you do
with your feelings actions yeah
not intentions not how you feel about
something on how upset something makes
you and not how your heart goes out your
actions make you a better person like a
being a position for Cortney yeah my
through line throughout my work my
feelings don't make you better
becoming we become like people who are
in a race for empathy though like I can
more compassionate than you yeah and
literally that's what it looks like if
you watch what people are doing their
interest race for being the most
compassionate person but as you said not
the person who acts that they don't do
anything they just they change their
profile picture everyone had the rainbow
or a pair they were in solidarity okay
we got dropped by audible because murder
that not gay Jared yes because we did a
pro-gun thing after Leonard like we
don't to be associated with anything
pro-gun and we were selling audible
subscriptions like crazy yeah we had a
post afterwards saying if you're gay you
should maybe get yourself a gun yeah two
little pink gun I want big 45 I found
online I liked that they put like a
rainbow decal something on it so like I
was like opalescent yeah it was a gay
looking gun but it was what's better
with the 45 because you don't have to do
any explaining as opposed to telling a
gay man to get a 9 right mm-hmm well
under the jokes is that a gun are you
just happy to see yeah that's a gun
yeah it's again it's phallic jokes so a
lot of people went to the dark side why
people are pumpkin this is it really is
it's a good point there is this and I do
see that on the right to which I do
think we're actually a mix of people
here it's a race to go like the my heart
sank my our hearts and prayers go out to
these people okay I guess that means so
much that but I mean we're people you
know if you tune an AM radio or you tune
into Fox News or you tune into a lot of
conservative media it's just like I
can't believe they said this or the flag
burning yeah right how dare you burn the
flag I'm like well I think you're kind
of a jackass but yeah
whatever you know I felt the same way
about the captaining thing like I did a
whole discussion about I thought it was
wrong for him to do it but he also
should have the right shirt for people
were I went to a football game in
Arizona and he was there and a guy in
the front row was saying that they
should kill him he was yelling it out
well and I thought okay this is where we
[Laughter]
doing
job of death but it still gets sacked
it's where we go on both sides though
when there's always that fringe and it's
the toleration of that if that's a word
of that fringe that bothers me on both
sides the whole Van Johnson the Jester
the common black name I forgive it right
but the the people the children are
waking up afraid of breakfast like what
did that mean like they saw a bowl of
cereal it spelled out Trump in half of
it cereal like when they're allowed to
say stuff like that on television
right or the other side yeah it makes it
to where real discussion can't be had so
that's why you have people trying to be
more empathetic than something that's
just I'm only allowed though it's
encouraged that's I've been behind the
curtain you know is it fun yeah for an
every major Network I've appeared and
Courtney knows I put like a more I just
said no I'm not doing any more media for
a while because of that and now I'll
probably get out a little bit more and
do it to promote the Daily Show but it
is that's actually encouraged it's
encouraged to be more outraged they
would rather have the outrage over the
salient point that needs to be made
because we've put such a great emphasis
on caring yeah so what well people don't
care when the red lights off yeah that's
a good point
yes purchasing it really does become a
problem because then that when there's a
serious problem or like OSU people that
people just become so desensitized to it
it's kind of like the racist cardrooms a
racist another yeah but you said that
about Mitt Romney and he's crying wolf I
can't think of anyone probably less
racist than Mitt Romney I mean you
probably could find someone but I've
never seen any proof that that man is
racist at all they had nothing on him
they they tried the binder full of women
and then he was the dog on the top of
the carcass the dog would get sick in
the car act that's what you've got
I mean I Jared what he heard that he's
equate that he actually did not throw my
cat in the pool floaties and then sprint
into the next one like if you throw it
in the water and it didn't swim is the
black hat bad luck see if we did that it
would be it's over
oh I joke mother Alton
can't black people swim Tommy I think
what's a [ __ ]
she was a problem but I don't know
because I'm a black guy that can't swim
my daughter can swim though but she got
a white pencil you guys can run really
fast
exactly yeah well it's absolutely true
you know for example we say well you
know what black people tend to run
faster no one has a problem with it yeah
and then if you say all the world
records and swimming are set by white
people or strength records
oh that's races like listen I'm not
saying black people can't swim not
saying black people are weak what I'm
saying is the guy from Poland with
fingers like sausages who couldn't
sprint whether Usain Bolt
but he can lift a thousand pounds over
his head people are genetically
different doesn't mean inferior or
superior it means we have different
assets and for some reason though I know
it's not for some reason I know exactly
why but you get to say it because you
know I can get away with it but I've
talked about that too I said why is it
that when with liberals and especially
blacks like if you say something about
the size of a man's whatever or you say
well they'll accept that even the guy
with like two inches will still say yeah
we got B and and you'll think why why is
it okay to say it's not considered
racist
Kourtney's calling H are considered
racist though if you say something
positive about a group yeah yeah but if
you say something considered negative
like when you bring up the stats of out
of birth out of wedlock births
yeah well that's racist to say that like
really like Ann Coulter gets killed for
talking about facts yeah on single
parents yeah because it's mean she might
also be a little racist but is very
white racism still be right that's true
yeah two things can't be true you David
Duke on your show didn't right
yeah but you've got to disagree with
some of that well I disagree with a lot
of things about David Duke but what
we've lost in like you talk about Tucker
or YouTube you can still have a
conversation with the individual can you
not yeah and when we have those echo
chambers as you spoke about where you go
to see him in and all you hear is what
they want you to hear anymore and what
they assume you want to hear yeah but
they won't let you hear the other side
will even have some people with this
show who will tune out or unsubscribe
because I've said you know I'm not
thrilled with all the cabinet picks of
Donald Trump and that's what we're not
just talking about left versus right but
people who get so in
with cheerleading mode and they turn off
their critical and be and yeah is
beholden to it in a lot of ways and
we've had to really kind of balance that
I'm sure you do as well really well I
know this will do well on line but I
also know that this is the truth and so
what we do is we train okay what is
truthful and then is it something that
people are interested in or they need to
learn about or we can make entertaining
but a lot of people just say well let's
look at a bunch of clicks and so add a
few exclamation marks and I don't know
say Obama's a Muslim or whatever it is
well any time we would report on Trump
well something that Trump actually said
that wasn't a good thing right people
got mad at us yeah okay you guys just
the messenger here this is what Trump
said yeah video Ram was one of the
things that attracted me to your program
other than the tight shirts but but it
was the idea that you would say one
thing one day a positive about a person
but you would critically look at what
they said the next day and not just be
the cheerleader because that to me is
the downfall of media what it's become
is I'm gonna cheerlead one side and if
it's something that I don't like or
maybe they said that was wrong I can't
point out you know what that's wrong I
don't agree with that you can't do that
anymore in media Wayne it's a slow built
for that kind of thing you know it's a
slow build when you do that you don't
get as many people who jump on the
bandwagon right away because it's a lot
easier to the rah rah rah Hey look at
our numbers because all we did was
praise Trump or on the flip side look at
our numbers because all we did was trash
Trump I mean that's why he became such a
media firebrand because it was great
ratings to just laud praise on him it
was great ratings to trash him it was
not you know you talked about the fringe
elements before Tommy where fringe no
really far right and really far left
know I'm probably to the right of Attila
Han I'm very conservative doesn't mean
I'm in line with a lot of republicanism
today but I don't think that's really
fringe anymore I think the middle has
become sort of a new friend I know
fringe we're using the term falsely or
not quite literally the fringe but I
think the middle here we're talking we
are a significant minority and I'm not
saying moderates I'm just saying people
who are trying to be at least somewhat
intellectually consistent and that's
become a real problem for a lot of
people it's difficult as you said it's a
slow build what we do is a slower build
because we're at least being critical
even of the people who we know or that
we like
and that's not something to build like
you can see people will have millions of
subscribers of things like this because
they will stick with that one view and
will be so adamant about it even when
it's false yeah I think that's true and
I think it's important to recognize that
and I think if you are consuming media a
lot you need to be aware of it you need
to guard your heart you need to be aware
of what you're consuming in and just
balance it we always tell people set
yourself some bookmarks and if you're
going to make one Drudge if you're gonna
make one right make the next one HuffPo
make the next one salon doesn't mean you
have to like it but you should know what
they're saying and of course this
program and join the mud clips are how
to get the plug in there Tommy said oh
man but Tommy oh it's over there on the
bar I'm gonna have to mug you we got
these madmen crystal a little pony so
hate you how much time do we have until
the segments I'm trying to think of what
else happened outside of Trump cabinet
picks here this week that we can talk
about because that just gets to the
point where it's just we don't know how
they do they don't know how they're
going to work yet and so I don't like to
do a lot of speculation yeah what do you
think about this well I like that price
is so rapidly anti Obama care I really
do hope that gets repealed that's one
thing I've Trump I'll be super pissed I
mean everybody's trying to link him to
the alt-right that was about then and
and I try and separate personal from
professional you know we talked about
this but you know Milo can't appear in
the show because
Beynon won't let him so we talked about
that you know he came on the debate Ben
Shapiro and you know I've never actually
had two conversations with Bannen but he
only sees people as friends and enemies
and you know used to work with Andrew
very closely so I try to separate that
from do I think he's a racist or an
anti-semite no do I understand some
concerns yeah I can understand some of
those concerns with people and again
that's me kind of being fair it's like
we can't have anyone from Breitbart in
the show until they leave Breitbart for
no real reason because they really are
on that insular echo chamber so that's
what concerns me about him but I don't
really think he's a racist not the
Goldman Sachs thing I know we don't have
much time but he's supposed to be the
person was throwing Goldman Sachs on
Hillary Clinton turns around he hires
all was a Goldman Sachs guy or Merrill
Lynch do you so what answer do you think
it's hypocritical for them to bring more
is it hypocritical yeah does it bother
me no because I know
people who work in investment banking
who work with hedge funds who are
against the bailouts so it depends to me
like you can work for goldman sachs and
say goldman sachs should have never been
bailed out so that's what matters to me
but no one wants to ask those questions
no one wants to say well what was his
position on the big Wall Street bailout
where's the consistency
if I had that answer it wouldn't matter
so not just like I don't say well cause
he's black don't hire him just says hey
JC speaks Yiddish and works at a bank I
don't I don't care I care what your
values are I care what your points of
view are Tommy's gonna my are a Courtney
Kerr job thank you very much we
appreciate we're gonna try and wrap this
show up
I'm now home alone but realistic I call
my first witness to the stand mr. herri
line as you can see your honor ladies
anyone on the jury mr. Lyme has to be
wheeled the witness stand today why is
that mr. lifts on a matchbox car
crushing your cervical spine and who put
that match car there your honor please
to the record show that my client aimed
his nub at mr. Kevin McAllister mr.
Harry Lime why don't you tell the jury
what your current process is like eating
breakfast he has to drink everything
through a straw because the horrible
disfigurement you see before you are
caused by third-degree burns by my
client being blow-torched
by mr. Kevin McAllister premeditatedly
and mercilessly on both the head and
face twice and mr. Harry Lime for the
jury to reiterate how did that occur
twice clever kid and lazy writing stay
tuned from all home alone but realistic
[Applause]
[Music]
got the mirror he did Samara Tommy
Sotomayor and Courtney Kerr Chow for
those yeah your microphone wasn't on
you're still learning how to actually be
professional in this setting there's no
hope for that it's a work in progress
here for people listening or washing to
rest really ar-15 or wonderful sponsors
of course partners at CR TV when we
first launched this pot this live stream
what a disaster it was that first one oh
we had a dry run it was so bad
still bad so by comparison this is an
absolute miracle this is an absolute
miracle I mean the worst we've had is
the yeah but you're you make sure you
shut off their microphones I don't think
we're gonna hear Tommy laughing over
there it's like having a studio audience
I know oh gosh you know I usually try
and do this this this sort of what's
your take away what's your take home and
we try and make it positive and the
reason for that is because everyone else
leaves it negative everyone else leaves
every program on a negative vibe so a
couple of things and tell me actually
suggested this so very very nice
gentleman there in a nice he's got that
you've got the vest but not the Rick
Santorum vest good stylish the wallace
and gromit uploads to be hop in the
water but a couple of things to go back
to we talked about this before about
having a servant's heart but that Vaux
situation
let me just read ress that it's one of
those we're constantly looking as to
what's fair and we're constantly looking
to how can we help the victim and even
for people out there who are very
empathetic even for people out there who
you know your intentions are true and I
believe that many of your intentions are
true
you may not realize how much you're
hurting rather than helping telling
people that they can't pay for their own
health care telling people that you know
what they can't pay for their own taxes
telling women that they can't afford
their own birth control or be sexually
responsible telling people that you need
to lend them a hand telling people that
you feel bad for them and that you know
gee whiz golly they need any welfare
reform so they can get more free stuff
doesn't matter what it is don't have to
be that extreme sometimes empathizing it
it cheats yourself of intellectual
honesty you want to be empathetic you
want to you want to try and think for
someone else's point of view you
absolutely shouldn't won't get to that
afterward but you if you're only looking
at how you can help that person at some
point you do have to ask hey you know
what how is that person empathizing was
anyone else how is that person actually
contributing or providing some kind of
silver lining in somebody else's life
and we often don't think about it
because we use the term fair fair
doesn't mean anything and so you don't
need to feel as though you need to be
beholden to fair particularly for some
kids who've you know gotten some
messages this week if you're in colleges
and they talk about what's not fair they
talk about your privilege they talk
about what you need to recognize they
talk about your advantages they talk
about affirmative action that would be
fair and so you feel guilty you don't
need to feel guilty you don't need to
feel guilty because of some arbitrary
term that is fair and fair is different
from just so it's good to be kind it's
good to be empathetic but you know what
that should be driven by some kind of an
intellectual compass and that's what
brings that's what we were talking about
here listen don't just look you don't
have to take my word for it as levar
burton says but he but then he direct
you toward a four-year-old or you read a
pop up down so since that's like levar
don't worry we want to have a smart man
but don't just listen to us don't take
our word for it question we get was
Courtney got this job here because she
insulted me she told me I was wrong
about something I'm trying to think who
else remember that day very very there
she told me the font on my website
sucked and I said you know what you're
right and if you do it in a way if
you're critical in a way you present new
ideas in a way that are
thought-provoking and like we said you
don't want to be a jerk
empathy combined with honesty he's an
unbelievably powerful tool people are
turning on this virtue signaling false
empathy because there's no one honesty
attached to it but when you combine the
two when you actually go out into the
world and you try to understand you try
to walk a mile on someone's shoes and
even if you say you know what maybe I
can't maybe I can't walk a mile in your
shoes as a black man as a woman as a
Latino whatever it is so I think I can
maybe understand where you're coming
from not fully but what about these laws
what about this information does this
change your point of view empathy in
combination with intellectual honesty is
incredibly powerful and we've seen that
in our life we've never had a single
liberal outside of Zack Ford who has
come on this show and wasn't willing to
come back and it's not for us being
gentle you know I certainly went that
with Sally Cohen or Christopher Titus
but we try to actually combine
intellectual honesty with empathy and we
really do try and be fair where we can
across the board and so that's what Russ
listen intellectual honesty can only
actually you can only put that as an
arrow in your quiver if you're informed
across the board if you're aware of what
other people are saying there's nothing
more embarrassing and I think this
happened once when I was in college
because I was a high school kid now is
better than today ting I got to college
and someone actually knew what they were
talking about and I realized oh wow I've
never heard this before and the left
that occurs with the left all the time
hence the Tucker Carlson viral posts now
right a lot of the left they there are
nays echo chambers they don't hear other
points of view there's nothing more
embarrassing than not understanding
other points of view so just going out
and saying make America great again I
love Trump doesn't help you it doesn't
serve you not only in in preventing
embarrassment for yourself but
convincing people so what can you do
well not only can you join the Mudd Club
of course not only can you inform
yourself by not only listen to us but
people who would oppose us people who
would oppose us with a passion would be
against everything we stand for
get that aggregate your information if
it's a branch if an argument is a branch
don't just start up the trunk go down
that branch and go down on every single
little limb and leave and know what
they're going to say so that you can
present an argument that is both
empathetic but intellectually honest and
you can't do that if you're staying in
the social media ghettos as Matt drudges
put it with people who only agree with
what you have to say you can't it can't
be done you need to inform yourself
across the board for empathy to even
seem genuine because how can you
empathize with somebody if you don't
even know what they're talking about and
how can you tell somebody that you don't
have the thighs with them if you don't
know what they're talking about you know
how can you look a Sally cone in the eye
or a tarik machine I know there's not a
lot of empathy there but how can you
look them in the eye and say okay I
understand where you're coming from
again you can only understand
intellectually not I feel you I feel you
brah I understand where you're coming
from because I've read what you're
coming from I've read your book I've
read the same articles that you read I
understand where you're coming from but
let me present to you this information
that's the way we will rise up a
generation of people who whether you're
conservative left centrist and that's
the way you can have the interactions
with people on a day-to-day basis that's
the way you can change hearts and minds
but it's got to start with honesty it
can't start with the fields empathy in
the absence of honesty is meaningless
and what am I looking for
right now from people in this country
intellectual diversity constitutional
conformity and empathy but only when
paired with intellectual honesty think
about that this week and that we'll see
you next week for the custom neon sign
you